Monal S: Hey, everyone!
Monal S: Good morning, good evening.
Monal S: Hello, guys, hello, hello.
Monal S: Good evening, guys, good morning.
Monal S: Bye.
Monal S: I hope everyone is doing well.
Monal S: Everyone is doing good. Good morning, Captain. Good morning, sailor.
Monal S: Morning, guys.
Monal S: How are you? I'm doing good, guys. I'm doing good.
Monal S: Good morning from Dubai. Yes, great, good morning.
Monal S: I'm doing good, guys. Good morning from USA. Oh, do we have morning in USA?
Monal S: Kritivas Raja. Hello guys, hello.
Monal S: I hope everyone has completed their assignments.
Monal S: Everyone?
Monal S: Reporting.
Monal S: Everyone revised previous classes. Thank you in advance. How are you? Looking forward today.
Monal S: Yes. I'm doing good, guys, thanks for asking.
Monal S: Thanks for asking, just joined, yes. The class will be starting in 4 minutes, it's 8.58, I will be for 9 or 2.
Monal S: And guys, it's a surprise. I can… someday, I can also start with 9. I can also start at, 9.2. I joined today my first class. Hey, Manish, welcome to the class.
Monal S: Thanks for joining us!
Monal S: Yes, completed pizza topping… pizza topping… yes. Guys, the assignment was given in such a way that some of them will only be solved by multiple ifs, some of them will only be solved by if-elif, some of them will be solved by if-else. So, I have added all of those things there so that you will be able to use your logic.
Monal S: Not everything can be solved by just if and else. Yes? How many of you felt that one of the solutions, require multiple ifs?
Monal S: Yes? Great, guys. Whoever is able to complete the assignment grades, this is the first step… first step. If you're not able to complete, please keep on revising, because that is how you're going to solve it. From the next assignment, I will also, give you what is the expected input and the output you will be receiving, alright? So that will help you.
Monal S: Imanol couldn't join the last financial due to some office meeting, joined last event recording, complete assignment. Thanks for the detailed explanation and your patience. Thank you very much. Thank you very much, Surya.
Monal S: See, guys, even if one non-tech people is able to understand.
Monal S: Who does not have any technical knowledge, and others are not able to understand.
Monal S: What is the actual bridge?
Monal S: Can we think of a bridge?
Monal S: If a non-tech person who does not know anything about tech is able to understand without any technical thing, is there any bridge left
Monal S: Is there any bridge left by which others are not able to understand? Yes, I will repeat few things again and again. Good morning, guys. I will repeat, tell you with the different things, but…
Monal S: There is 100% of work that you have to do once you reach… once this class is over.
Monal S: BAS, correct.
Monal S: Correct, Feroz. You… the bridge is your practice.
Monal S: I can see a lot of you are not practicing, and guys, we have seen that people even join Agentic AI course, and does not even know how to print things. Simple print function. They don't even know that.
Monal S: So, who is at fault? Others.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Guys… Tell me in which scenarios it is possible to, have an evaluation.
Monal S: Guys, assignments… Nitin, is this your first class, Nathan?
Monal S: Nitin, is this your first class?
Monal S: So, where we do get, assignments.
Monal S: Nathan, have you attended previous class?
Monal S: Guys, assignment is something which is not mandatory from your side. I'm just giving you guys questions to solve it, that's all.
Monal S: Evaluation is something I'm giving you basic thing. From when the class gets harder, when the problem shipment gets harder, I will give you input and output. If you pass that input, you get that output, it means your evaluation is done. We code base like that. Alright, so guys, it is already 9.01.
Monal S: where can we find it?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Yes. Are we ready? Guys, are we ready for today's class? I will answer each and everything. Are we ready?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Alright, great.
Monal S: Guys, let's forget about the assignment. If you keep on chatting, I will listen to, one of the reviews and feedback that we got to disable the chat.
Monal S: Do you want that? How many of you want that?
Monal S: So that I can be sane as well.
Monal S: Disable the chat.
Monal S: So please, whenever I say, let's get started, we will get started, let's focus here.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Alright, so I'm sharing my screen. I hope my screen is visible, everyone.
Monal S: Is my screen visible? Correct. So, this is 24… 24 January 2026, we are in Python 4, only 4th class of Python, and we have done so much.
Monal S: Today, I'm going to discuss on resource in the first 5 to 10 minutes, then we will jump to non-permitted data types, while loop, function, and function argument.
Monal S: Alright, are we clear with the agenda?
Monal S: Everyone, are we clear with the agenda?
Monal S: Great. Okay? So, I'm not going to show this part again, don't say, sir, please show, please show, and you are going to repeat it. Just look at the screen, I'm not going to repeat it, it is pretty straightforward.
Monal S: Alright, so this is our learn.krishnaacademy.com. What I did is, if you go to the courses, okay, and go to your Krishna, and go to your batch too, everyone, and go to your batch too.
Monal S: you will see something like this, and you will see one other section got added. Which section got added, guys?
Monal S: Which section got added?
Monal S: Miss.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: This section got added. It is not a part of this course, but I want all of you, because some of them are facing issue. I'm not sure what is actually the big deal to find the resource. If you click on any of this file, the resource is always there. People say, where is resource, where is resource?
Monal S: I don't understand that how hard it is to find your classes.
Monal S: look on the web, and this is your video, this is your resource. Always, this is your video, this is your resource. Alright? To make things simpler, alright, I'm not going to maintain this all the time, but this is…
Monal S: Till I am teaching you. Here, you can see Mentor 1 reference. Who is Mentor 1? I am Mentor 1, alright? If you click here, if you click here, you can see…
Monal S: Let's see, is everyone able to see this quick resource reference link? When you click on reference, it gives you this blank white page where we have the link. If you click on link, it will open a new page.
Monal S: I hope everyone is able to see this new page, or just to show you, I will open in a new incognito mode, because I have logged in via my mail. So this is how it will look like to everyone. Yes?
Monal S: Is everyone able to see?
Monal S: Are you able to see access sheet, what is the class date, what is topics, and also you will be able to see some link, Google Drive links, of the resource.
Monal S: I want all of you, once the class is over, read all of this.
Monal S: Read all of this, I'm not going to maintain, this is not going to maintain for 3 years. What we have guaranteed is, in live sessions, you will always find… so LMS is the original source used, you guys, but
Monal S: till the time I'm teaching, I'm going to maintain this. Read all the important notes, I have mentioned each and everything. This page is active only while Monul Singh is learning the instruction, leading the instruction, alright? Here you can see there are a few sections, announcement. Announcement is something like, I need to announce you something, alright? Beforehand. So, if you click on Announcement, this page will open.
Monal S: Are we able to see the coming announcement?
Monal S: that coming holiday data science best 2.0, at… in 28… on 28th January, that is Wednesday, we have holiday.
Monal S: Is everyone clear beforehand?
Monal S: whenever I talk about some LinkedIn post which will help you, or that is something, I will keep on attaching here. AI Roadmap. This is the AI Roadmap which I have given before, yes?
Monal S: Did I show you this roadmap before?
Monal S: I showed you this roadmap before? Yes.
Monal S: System laptop recommendation, this is, again, my LinkedIn post. Don't worry, I will not just paste my LinkedIn, but others, but for now, I am just maintaining a few things. You guys can check it, alright? Now, here, if you go back, there is a FAQ section. FAQ here will be class timings. Lot of people just keep on asking what is class timing. I have mentioned UTC plus 5. UTC plus
Monal S: plus 530, UTC 5, UTC 0, UTC8.
Monal S: IST timings, EST, GMT, SDT. Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: How do doubt sessions work? Read all of this.
Monal S: When do we take doubt, when we don't take doubt? What topics, what doubt we should be asking? How to see course curriculum? Course curriculum link is also present.
Monal S: Is everyone clear now?
Monal S: And no one should have more expectation from this one, I'm just keeping everything in a single file. Today's resource, after 15-20 minutes, the class is over, I will be adding it.
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Alright? Done. So, everyone will be able to access it. Done.
Monal S: So, this part is over, let me close it. Can you share the link again? Same thing, guys, do you want me to share this link?
Monal S: How many… you don't have access to the website? Are you working with Terminal? Are you watching your WebEx or this meeting with Terminal?
Monal S: Are you missing mouse, keyboard?
Monal S: See, I want you guys to do more and more work, okay? I'm also doing more work. Great. Is this part good, everyone? Is this clear?
Monal S: So, discussion on resource is clear, but if you don't read whatever I've written, I will not answer anything on that. Alright?
Monal S: Great. So, guys, I know, people are not focused. Yes, guys, I'm disabling chat because I can see a lot of people are just keep on focusing. I will disable it, let's try it for the first day. I will disable it for 20 minutes, then we'll check once the topic is over. Alright? Yeah, let's see that.
Monal S: Because of other people's mistake, other people has to suffer.
Monal S: Alright, great. So…
Monal S: Attendees can chat with no one for 20 minutes. Until I've covered one topic, then I will ask a, doubt.
Monal S: Okay, no one will be able to chat now. Second topic is non-primitive data types. If you again focus on keyboard, you will miss something, okay? Non-primitive data part.
Monal S: None.
Monal S: primitive data types.
Monal S: Previously, we have seen that there are basic data types that are integer, float, string, others, right? When we go to object-oriented programming, you can check in the syllabus, we will understand more about these non-primitives, what are classes, and other things. But for now, these are variables which hold value. But when we want to hold values in a more efficient way, we kind of use more advanced type of data types.
Monal S: in order to handle our situations. One of the advanced data types which we have seen is… I'm not going to repeat advanced, but I will just say a type of data, alright? Data type.
Monal S: So, one of them which we have already learned is LIST.
Monal S: Alright? List.
Monal S: List.
Monal S: I think when I'm zooming in, it is kind of messed up.
Monal S: So, let's start with the list.
Monal S: Now, let me write the properties of list.
Monal S: List, when we add something to the list, When we add…
Monal S: It's better to just write everything in text.
Monal S: That my writing will not come as well.
Monal S: Correct.
Monal S: Crosspoint.
Monal S: When we append something to the list, right? When we append something to the list, 8.
Monal S: maintains the… order of append, okay? It means that
Monal S: It means that if this is my list L,
Monal S: If this is my list L,
Monal S: L is equals to empty list. And when I do L.Append, when I do L.append of 0, this list is going to have
Monal S: This list is going to have zero.
Monal S: When I again append, When I again append 2,
Monal S: Then this list is going to look like 0,2.
Monal S: So, whatever we are adding, it's not like it is automatically sorting itself, right? When we add 0, 0 is at the start. When we add 2, 2 is after the 0. So, it maintains the order in which we are adding the value, alright? That is list.
Monal S: Second point. Second point about list.
Monal S: It accepts… Any data type.
Monal S: It accepts any data types, even duplicates
Monal S: are allowed. You will understand later that why I'm writing about duplication, because there are some data types which we are going to introduce in non-primitive, which does not allow duplicates, but list allows duplicates. It means that if I append, it means that if I append.
Monal S: If I append 2 again, I will see 2 again, alright? Multiple 2 can also exist in a single list. That is totally fine in terms of list, alright? Now let's talk about the methods which list introduces.
Monal S: Everyone should be familiar with method and function, alright? Method.
Monal S: So, what methods list have? We have already seen one of the methods, that is append. And everyone knows what append uses. This is what append looks like, and let me write about append. That is…
Monal S: Not like that.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Hoping.
Monal S: Append is… Add an element, slash value, to the end.
Monal S: I hope everyone knows this part, alright? Now let's talk about pop.
Monal S: What pop does? There is another element called as pop, because people were saying that we are able to append values, we are able to add values, but how to delete values? Well, there is a way. We use pop for that, okay? Remove by index. I will talk about what is index, don't worry, I will start again.
Monal S: And then, for now, let's use only pop and append, because these are the main ones. Now, I will talk about…
Monal S: Just wait.
Monal S: Now I will talk about the internal structure of LIST, and how to access it.
Monal S: Let me write.
Monal S: accessing… list elements. And guys, whenever I say elements, it means value, okay? Or values.
Monal S: So… Let's just understand this by an example. Let's suppose this is…
Monal S: counter. This is counter. Some person is standing here, okay? Some person is standing here.
Monal S: And there is a queue of people.
Monal S: There is a queue of people.
Monal S: Think of queue of people as elements of list.
Monal S: Okay, elements of list.
Monal S: As currently, we are talking about accessing list elements and values. Now, my problem statement is, if I want to call person 4,
Monal S: if I want to call person 4, who is standing in this queue, how can I call person 4, right? This is my current problem statement. How do we generally use it? Person who is standing first to the counter will be given a number called as 1.
Monal S: Person who's standing second, second, third, fourth.
Monal S: for 5th. Yes?
Monal S: This is how we do in real world. In real world, whoever is standing at the last does not get a number of 1.
Monal S: whoever is standing near to the original counter, the main counter, will be given a number of 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. So, when I give them number, now I will be able to solve the problem. Problem like, if this person wants to call
Monal S: wants to call person 4, they know where… which person is 4 here. Which person is person 4? This is person 4. Because we know that this is their position, we have already given them a number 1, 2, 3, 4.
Monal S: Similar happened to list, alright? Similar things happens to list. Now, this is a list variable called SL. I will be placing some values like…
Monal S: Hello.
Monal S: Hello is my first.
Monal S: Then, hey!
Monal S: Second… then I will write Python…
Monal S: then I will write 10 as a value, then I will write false as a value.
Monal S: And just to recap, this is a string, this is a string, this is a string, this is an integer, this is a boolean.
Monal S: I hope everyone should remember it. So, ideally, if I want to call… if I want to call 10, 10 is present in 1, 2, 3, 4. 10 is present in 4th, but this is a programming language, some things change, but the main logic remains same.
Monal S: That is, whoever is standing near the counter will get the initial number. Similar things happen in the list, but this is programming. In programming, in programming, we start the counting from 0, not with 1.
Monal S: Alright? This happens in Java, this happens in C++, C, every programming language. Same happens with Python. So instead of giving them 1, we will start with 0. 1, 2, 3, 4.
Monal S: I hope this is clear, guys. We don't start with 1, we always start with 0, so in Python, the counting starts with 0.
Monal S: Alright? And all of these things which we're talking about, they are position. In programming languages, we call them as index. This is an index, this number itself is called as index.
Monal S: Alright? So, index is a number which tells the position of an element in a list. Again, I'm repeating, index is a number which tells the position of an element or a value in the given list.
Monal S: So, just like this person who is on the counter was calling person 4, they just mentioned call 4. Here, we do the similar thing, we will use their index. So, what we will do, L is the list. See this, how… if I want to call number 10, number 10 indexes 3.
Monal S: Number 10 indexes 3. So, how we're going to call 10? We will mention this is the list.
Monal S: And then we need to write the index in square bracket.
Monal S: So when we write L of 3, or we should read it like third index of list 3.
Monal S: third index. Not third index, Index 3.
Monal S: index 3 of list L.
Monal S: So what value is present in index 3 of list L? 0, 1, 2, 3. That is 10.
Monal S: So when we write L of 3, it will give us 10. I will show you the practical now.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: So, here we're talking about non… primitive… data types.
Monal S: Okay, so as we have seen, I have created a list. So let me create L is equals to, let's say, hello.
Monal S: Then I will write… Hey, let me zoom in.
Monal S: This is better for everyone than Python.
Monal S: Then I mentioned 10, then I think I've mentioned 4ths.
Monal S: Alright, I have mentioned false. My list is created. It is connected to the kernel. It will take some time, because I've just started my system. Usually, it doesn't take time. That's it.
Monal S: Don't worry, I will start the chat session.
Monal S: Okay? But after showing you all the things.
Monal S: After you guys are focusing here.
Monal S: Do I need to restart my VS Code?
Monal S: Hopefully not.
Monal S: way it works
Monal S: Let me close it.
Monal S: Alright, let me start VS Code, because now it is… Not working that correctly.
Monal S: Detecting kernels. Kernel is detected. No, I don't want that. Let's run it.
Monal S: See how fast it is now? It was an issue with the VS Code, okay? All software has some issue. Now, what I told you, I want to access the value, and I want to see the value as well. So, I will be using print, then I will be using the variable L, because that is what list is, then I want to access the value of 10. 10 is present in.
Monal S: This is 0 index, 1 index, 2nd, and third.
Monal S: Okay? So if I write 10 here.
Monal S: Oh, not 10. I write 4, sorry. 4 is… 3 is the index. 0, 1, 2, 3.
Monal S: Are we getting 10? Yes, we are getting 10. Here, if I just want to replace with 0,
Monal S: it gives us help, alright? So Python also gives you… see, there's… this is some issue with Microsoft VS Code.
Monal S: It's fine.
Monal S: Let's cancel it. If everything is working.
Monal S: Then, it does not have an issue.
Monal S: Let's cancel this.
Monal S: Is it working again? Yes, it is able, it is working, no issue.
Monal S: Alright, so we have seen that using index, we can access the elements. I will talk about what exactly, the use of it, alright? But this is the programming languages, we have multiple, problems as well, right? The first problem is, in real world, let's suppose there are
Monal S: Hundreds of people standing.
Monal S: The last people standing is 102.
Monal S: This person currently does not know… if this person currently does not know what is the last person, what this person is going to do in the real world. In the real world, person is going to count each and every person, and then will give a token of 102 to this person. Then only this person will know that the last
Monal S: That the last person token ID is 102.
Monal S: This is what happens in real world. But in Python, we don't have a person who's going to count it.
Monal S: And we require a better optimal solution. Yes, Python can also count it, 0, 1, 2, 3, 4. But we… if I give you a problem statement, something like this, because we are coders, if I give you a problem statement.
Monal S: That… I want… To know… the last value of list.
Monal S: Now, let's break this particular problem statement. First, if the index was 0, if the question is something like, if the quotient is something like.
Monal S: Get the… First value.
Monal S: We know that, in Python, the list index, any index starts from 0. So when I talk about the first value, it means I need to access an index of 0. But if someone asks that, get the last value.
Monal S: To get the last value, the first thing I need is, I need its index. I don't know the last element, so I don't know the index. So, how can I solve this particular problem? Well.
Monal S: the list gives you multiple flexibility. List gives you two directions. In this particular direction, let me show you, in this direction.
Monal S: In this direction.
Monal S: index… starts with… Zero.
Monal S: Alright? Index starts with 0.
Monal S: Now, there is another direction.
Monal S: In this direction, It starts with… minus 1.
Monal S: I know this is a little confusing, but I will show you now, everything will make sense.
Monal S: Here, it was starting with 0. So 0 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1. If you do 0 plus 1, you will get 1. If you do 1 plus 1, you will get 2. So, it is 1 increment. Index is 0, 1, 2, 3, 4. Here, I'm seeing that it starts with minus 1.
Monal S: Now, if I add minus 1 plus 1, it will give you 0. That is not how this particular direction is going to flow. The first will minus 1,
Monal S: Then, minus 2, then minus 3, then minus 4.
Monal S: So, there are two directions which we can access. So, if I talk about all the values… so, see, this one is minus 2, minus 3, minus 4, minus 5.
Monal S: So, similarly, now, if I want to access… if I want to access, Ben.
Monal S: If I want to access 10,
Monal S: 10 has, in this particular direction, that is, from left to right, we just need to write L of 3.
Monal S: Yes, in this direction, we need to write L of… what is the index? Minus 2.
Monal S: Both of them is going to give me 10.
Monal S: How it is going to solve the last value problem?
Monal S: We know that the last value, the index start from the reverse is minus 1. So, if I just write.
Monal S: index of… Minus 1, this means that it is the last element.
Monal S: Let's see that.
Monal S: I don't know the index.
Monal S: I don't know the last value. I want to get the last value. See, if I just write minus 1,
Monal S: Is minus 1 false? Yes. Now, if I want to get 10, I will write minus 2.
Monal S: Yes, I hope everyone is able to understand how List works.
Monal S: Alright? How list works? So, I've written everything here.
Monal S: So now, let me enable the chat.
Monal S: A small, short topic is done.
Monal S: Guess?
Monal S: Guys, was this good? Was everyone able to understand everything in depth? Now you guys can comment.
Monal S: Yes? All clear?
Monal S: Perfect. Great session.
Monal S: Don't worry, I will give you everything, okay?
Monal S: All clear. Great.
Monal S: I feel like this is also better. See, I'm also up to trial and error, okay? Whatever is… yes.
Monal S: Yes, Lakshmi Kant, I will tell you. Okay? I will tell you. Better to keep chat disabled.
Monal S: Guys, we will figure it out, every batch has a different requirement, don't worry, my duty is to teach you everyone, okay? Teach everyone here. So, I'm not going to leave anyone.
Monal S: Negita, I will show you, don't worry.
Monal S: Julie, we can get it.
Monal S: You can also do that. There are two methods, but this is the native method, Julie.
Monal S: Yes, Rohit, you can use it. Now, can I start the next part, guys?
Monal S: Can I start the next part? We'll teach you more when the list is not completed.
Monal S: Guys, whatever I'm showing you, that is the method which you need to work, okay? Great. Disabling…
Monal S: Zoom in, please. I will zoom in, don't worry.
Monal S: Stuck.
Monal S: Disabled.
Monal S: Alright, so now, let's understand few more things.
Monal S: Let me copy our list again.
Monal S: I know there are a lot of things now in our list.
Monal S: I don't want to copy it all.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: So there is a function, okay, not method. There is a function in Python called as length.
Monal S: Alright? In length, if you provide… in length, if you provide a string, in length, if you provide a string, it will count characters. It will count its characters.
Monal S: In length, if you provide a list.
Monal S: If you provide a list variable, or a list itself, it will count Total… Number of elements or values.
Monal S: Alright? So, first, let's see this. Here, I'm talking about function called as length.
Monal S: L-E-N. Function, alright? It is not related to list, it can be used with list as well. So, in length, if I write data.
Monal S: Data consists of 4 characters, 1, 2, 3, 4, we are getting 4.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Here, if I write the list, our list is L. How many values we have in list? 1, 2, 3, 4, and 5. So let's write…
Monal S: Hell here.
Monal S: 5. Great.
Monal S: So, if we don't know minus 1, if we don't… if we don't want to use this minus 1, minus 2, we can also use the final length. We are getting the length. Now, see one issue. Now, this is what you need to… this is not an issue, but you need to understand how Python works. If I write L,
Monal S: And I don't want to use minus 1. And I don't want to use minus 1. I want to use the final index. Final index is…
Monal S: 0, 1, 2, 3, 4. So, final index is 4.
Monal S: Lot of people, what they do, they just write the length of L. This will give you 5. If you paste length of L here, Python will throw an error.
Monal S: it will say, list index out of range. Why? Because what we are telling to Python, what we are telling to Python, that length of L, length of L gives you 5. You can see the output, it means it has 5 values. We are giving 5.
Monal S: And if we check the L,
Monal S: The total, the final index is 4. This is 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Monal S: So, we have 5 values, but we have total number of 5 index starting from 0. That's why Python is saying that you are trying to access an index of 5, which does not even exist. List index not in range. So, what we need to do? We need to do length of L-1.
Monal S: So, always list index is going to be having length of L-1 as the final index.
Monal S: I'm able to access false. So you can… you can do minus from here, minus 2, but why to do that? Is everyone able to see? We are already doing the subtraction.
Monal S: So why do you even use length?
Monal S: Both of them are the same thing. If I do length of L minus 1, it gives us the final. That is, 5 minus 4 will give you… 5 minus 1, sorry, okay? This will be, like, 5 minus 1.
Monal S: 5-1 will be solved to… with Python, 5 minus 1 will be solved to 4. So, at the end, Python will use…
Monal S: Length of 4. Not length. L of 4, sorry.
Monal S: Okay? And L of 4 will give you false, that is the last element. We are still using minus 1.
Monal S: And we know that Python, by default, gives us the functionality.
Monal S: That is, from reverse. That is the same thing.
Monal S: Yes, this is in reverse direction, this is in forward direction. Here, we are doing more things. We are asking Python to calculate the length, then do some subtraction, then do it. But here, only one step is here. From reverse, just write minus 1, minus 2, minus 3.
Monal S: Similarly, if I write, from reverse, how many values we have? Minus 1, minus 2, minus 3, minus 4, minus 5. So I can access still minus 5.
Monal S: But if I try to access 6, minus 6,
Monal S: Again, the same error, because the index which we are trying to extract does not even exist in this particular list. So that will give you index out of range error.
Monal S: Alright, so here we have seen length, how to use length. Length can be used with multiples, we will see later. We have seen that. Length already works with string, length also works with list. Using length, we can do all of this, work with index.
Monal S: Alright? Again, for 2 minutes, I'm enabling it. I hope everyone is clear with length.
Monal S: Everyone's length is simple.
Monal S: Length is simple, very simple.
Monal S: Don't worry, I will introduce things again and again whenever it needed. Which method is faster?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Alright. See, guys, I'm just asking here, is length clear? I will talk about the other concepts.
Monal S: Guys, why it is applicable to string?
Monal S: I told you, in string, a string consists of characters.
Monal S: I showed you that we can iterate over string as well, yes or no?
Monal S: Yes or no?
Monal S: Yes. Alright, so this answers. Now, let me go to the next part.
Monal S: Data written 4, data written 4, counting the character through L written 5 element.
Monal S: Guys…
Monal S: Julie, I was talking about L. L is 5. Data is 4. This is just a string. We were always working with the list which we created. Julie, are we clear?
Monal S: This is just to show that string work… length works with string as well. This 4 is coming, but you can see this 5? This 5 of L.
Monal S: Why not care in the L?
Monal S: Julie, L is list. It trades value element by element. This is 1 element, this is 2 element, this is 3 element, this is 4 element, this is 5 element.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Okay, okay, one doubt that people are having, let me show you, alright?
Monal S: Guys, length gives you… Total…
Monal S: number of elements. I told you, it gives you total number of elements. If I will ask you to count how many elements are present.
Monal S: Will you say 2? Do you see it too?
Monal S: index… Is not equals to number of elements.
Monal S: Index is telling us the position, 0, 1, 2. Length tells you total number of elements, that is 3.
Monal S: is this part here. Final index is 2. Length is not 2.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Anurag, you need to check it, how print works, and length works.
Monal S: Guys…
Monal S: How many of you have doubt that why length work with a string without even passing it like this?
Monal S: Why this worked, why this… why this worked.
Monal S: Because I told you, even if you pass length of L, guys, this is the first class I taught you.
Monal S: Even if you pass something to a Python, Python will take… this is not a variable, this is a variable which holds the address. Python will internally convert it to what is the value of A, then it will look like this.
Monal S: Did I not taught you this?
Monal S: Guys, did I not teach you this?
Monal S: Alright, let's jump to the next part. Guys, I… yes.
Monal S: Please repeat pop, and guys, I've not yet started on the pop.
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Now, we understood that what is length? Length is some function which counts things. Count is different from index, guys, a lot of people get confused, okay? Count is different from… index is a property of Python, and it starts with counting things from zero. But when we talk about total number of something.
Monal S: Then we will start with normal mathematics, start from 1, 2, 3. We don't count, we don't say this is… we don't say that now there are 1 people.
Monal S: Because I'm counting from 0.
Monal S: In real world, count itself means that start from 1 and 2. So, we will follow the counting from 1, but index will start from 0. That's why we are having it, alright? Now, as I mentioned, that in list, we were able to add something, we were able to access something. Now, if you want to delete something, what we should do?
Monal S: So, we were able to understand append
Monal S: Append we use to add something, add element.
Monal S: not the addition, but add means adding value into the list, alright? Then, I told you length used to count
Monal S: things. Just used to count things, alright? Then we also understood the index used to… Access… value of…
Monal S: list.
Monal S: Or elements of list. Now, let's talk about pop.
Monal S: So, pop is element used to remove elements from list.
Monal S: Remove elements from list, alright? So, pop has, by default, argument of 0. If you don't write anything in pop, series how to use pop, alright?
Monal S: Let's jump here, and let's talk about pop. Guys, I'm keeping the error because error is something which you should also learn. Why some error is coming?
Monal S: Alright? So, pop.
Monal S: So when I write L, that is our list, and when I do method, because, as I told you, append and pop is a method, so method should be used with dot against the list.
Monal S: So, I will use pop. Just like append.append, I'm using pop. If I don't provide anything in the pop, by default, it is going to consider… by default, it is going to consider the last element to pop.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: By default, behavior… Is to remove last element.
Monal S: Last element. So let's print the last element first.
Monal S: This is our list. We have hello, hey, Python 10 false. And once I pop it, we will print it as well.
Monal S: So, it gives you what element it popped, alright? But now, if you print list.
Monal S: The false is not present which was present before.
Monal S: So when you run L.pop, it also tells you which value it removed, but when you print the last… when you print the actual list, you can see the false is not present.
Monal S: Alright? Now, if you specifically want to remove some value, that is, the zeroth index, hello, let's remove the 10. Okay, hello is fine.
Monal S: Alright? If you specifically want to remove hello from the new list, guys, this is the new value of the list, false is not present. Don't say, sir, we are… now the false should be present, no. False is removed permanently. If you want to add it, we can add it again. Let's append true here.
Monal S: Now, if I print L, you can see true is appended. Now, I want to remove hello. Hello index is 0. I will say L.pop, and when I pass the index, it will remove that index value.
Monal S: What it removed?
Monal S: L.pop tells you that it removed hello.
Monal S: Now let's print L. Yes.
Monal S: Hello is removed, now all the value will shift to the left side, because… see this, all the values shifted to the left side, because previously in list, we have some elements. This is element 1, 2, 0, 1, 2, 3.
Monal S: If we remove it, all the elements will now shift one position. So that's why we will see the new values like this.
Monal S: If this was… 0, 1, 2, 3.
Monal S: Nowadays.
Monal S: 1, 2, 3. But again, this will become… this value will become the new 0, this value will become the new one, this value will become the new. I'm talking about index, alright? So that's why we are able to see the similar thing here.
Monal S: Hey now becomes the 0th index, Python now becomes the 1 index. Previously, Python was 2, now Python is 1. Because we removed hello, everything got shifted towards the left, because there was an empty position.
Monal S: Alright? So, it's now, guys, I've enabled the chat. Is everyone clear with how to use POP?
Monal S: Is everyone clear how to remove with pop?
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Again, disabling because… If we don't know the yes, correct. Correct.
Monal S: Guys, you can remove minus 1.
Monal S: It's totally fine. Index is index. Index is index.
Monal S: Alright, again disabling, now let's see.
Monal S: Next is… What to do when… We don't know… the index… of element… We want to remove.
Monal S: But we know… The value we want to remove.
Monal S: Let me… Say this in two lines.
Monal S: Yes, this is also a problem statement. Here, this time, let's suppose my list contains… This time.
Monal S: My list contains…
Monal S: My list contains… Thousands of element.
Monal S: thousands of an event, okay? And I want to remove… and I want to remove a word
Monal S: I want to remove… A word called as hey.
Monal S: Alright? And I don't know the index, because hey can be present in any of this thousand element, I don't remember, because there are a lot of elements. So I cannot use pop, because pop works with… in pop, we need to provide the index.
Monal S: In append, we provide value.
Monal S: Similar kind of method that is provided by list is called as remove.
Monal S: Remove accepts value.
Monal S: If the… if the value matches to the list element, it will remove that.
Monal S: Alright? So let me show you that. Remove method.
Monal S: We will use Timo.
Monal S: Here, I will write L dot remove.
Monal S: Alright? And here, you can see that it is giving us value. And what it removes? It removes the first occurrence only.
Monal S: it removes the first occurrence. So let me show you that here in this L, I will append 2HE.
Monal S: Edge E1.
Monal S: And let's print Elk again.
Monal S: Here we can see, hey, Python, pan, true, hey.
Monal S: And I'm telling remove to remove HEY. See this same case. Capital H, small EY. If I say HEY, nothing will get removed because it is not matching. Python is case sensitive. All programming languages are case sensitive.
Monal S: So I want to remove hay, and as we have seen that, it will only remove the first occurrence of a value.
Monal S: Let's run it. Removed. Let's print L.
Monal S: First occurrence was, starting from 0, it removed the first hit.
Monal S: If I run this again, if I run this again, is there any hay other than the last one? No.
Monal S: Let's run it. Let's print L, all the hey got removed.
Monal S: Yes? So, if we don't know the index, it will… we can use remove.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: So, this is SPOP.
Monal S: Usually, we use POP, you will see POP a lot because you're going to learn a lot of data structures, alright? Last in first house is also a concept that is… that uses it, but don't worry about it.
Monal S: So this completes our list.
Monal S: Is everyone clear with the list? All the questions are answered.
Monal S: All the questions are answered.
Monal S: Removes the first occurrence.
Monal S: work on, like, I remove 10…
Monal S: Sir, we want to remove all hay, suppose we have 100.
Monal S: I want to do a lot of things, guys, there are a lot of things, but, it is not always…
Monal S: uses functions.
Monal S: How to delete all occurrence? Guys, for that, you need to write Python code.
Monal S: Okay? You will be using Python code to remove all the occulants off here.
Monal S: Surya, I will also tell you, but right now… okay.
Monal S: No.
Monal S: Rahul, did I ever taught that list and area are both same? No. List and area are never seen.
Monal S: I've already cleared it.
Monal S: Rithik, this is a data structure of Python itself.
Monal S: What is non-primitive data types? Those are data structures, complex data structures.
Monal S: Yes, guys, next… Sir, in your explanation, both the hay got removed because I'd run it 2 times. Hush.
Monal S: Are you not doing it?
Monal S: Alright, guys, I'm disabling the chat, now see this.
Monal S: Now, some people are asking that if I want to add, if there are two values like this.
Monal S: If there are 3 values like this.
Monal S: And instead of using append, I want to add 4, and append will append the 4 here.
Monal S: But what happens if I want… but what to do when I want to append this 4 between 0 and 10?
Monal S: What should I do? There is another method. Guys, we are not going to cover each and every method, because…
Monal S: later, once… if you require it, then only you will use it. So, insert is a method of list, which will insert something in between, okay? Whatever index you give it. Suppose I want to insert 4, I want to insert 4 at index 1.
Monal S: So, what I want, I want 4 to be the new index 1. So, if I do that, what will happen? 0 will remain 0, because this is 0th index.
Monal S: I want 4 at index 1, so when I insert 4 in between this.
Monal S: I will get 4 as 1. What will happen to the 10? 10 will be shifted.
Monal S: So I was able to insert one here. So if you want to see the same.
Monal S: If you want to see the same, See, now this one has…
Monal S: Python 10 and true. So, I will do what? I will insert. At what index? Let's suppose at index this is 0, 1, 2. I want to insert at index 2, but I want to insert what? I also need to tell, I need to tell at what index you want to insert, and what you want to insert.
Monal S: Let's suppose I want to insert machine learning At index 2.
Monal S: Let's see the L.
Monal S: Machine learning is now the index 2. True got shifted. Anything that is before index 2 will remain as it is.
Monal S: Done. So, this completes our list. Guys, there are a lot of functions, lot of methods which we can use, but for now, whatever is required for the learning, we will learn that, alright? So, let me write and conclude the list, then I will talk about the other elements, okay?
Monal S: So, in list, we have seen… Append.
Monal S: We have seen… index concept.
Monal S: Index is a concept. We use it via append and other things, right? And then we have seen…
Monal S: Bob?
Monal S: we have seen… Insert, we have seen remove.
Monal S: These are the methods of list. It will not work with a variable, just like it will not work with an integer.
Monal S: Okay, it will work with list data type.
Monal S: Alright, so this completes our list. Now let's talk about the next data type, which is very, very, very important.
Monal S: called as dictionary. So let me copy and paste everything that we have written here.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Dictionary, or in short, we call it as dict. D-I-C-T, but let me write full thing.
Monal S: dictionary.
Monal S: Alright? And dictionary, you should remember it by the key…
Monal S: value payer. For beginners, this is kind of something which will scare you, but once you practice for one day, for two days, it will be very simple, alright? But make sure that you practice this a lot, because when we go to agent take care LLMs, we communicate with LLMs
Monal S: From web technologies, that is from HTML, CSS, JavaScript, to Python, Java, we communicate with dictionaries, alright? In Python, we call it as dictionaries, but for other languages, like JavaScript, we call them as JSONs.
Monal S: Alright? But make sure that you practice this a lot, because this is very important to understand. It is not at all hard, but for beginners, because it looks complex, it is little hard at the start.
Monal S: Dictionary, the key value pair.
Monal S: Dictionary is used to store Data with labels.
Monal S: data with labors. Yes, list does have labels called as index, but you will understand that what exactly we mean by labors, how it is useful. I will tell you. Instead of labels, and labels, we will call it as keys.
Monal S: Alright? Instead of positions, or index.
Monal S: Right? Instead of positions. Index will be used, but instead of positions. So, what does it mean?
Monal S: Let me show you.
Monal S: Alright, let me first complete it.
Monal S: So, key should be… Key must be… either string.
Monal S: Or numbers, or we will learn something that is one of the data types which we will learn.
Monal S: Key must be either of this. It can be numbers, it can be string, it can be tuples. Tuples is, again, another data type which we are going to learn.
Monal S: And values can be anything.
Monal S: just like list values can be anything, here, the values of dictionary can be anything, but there is a new concept of key, alright? So when I… let's think of it as, like.
Monal S: Person 1.
Monal S: Okay? Let's think of it as, like, I have my details. I have my details of date of birth, this is one of my details. I have my few details, like phone number.
Monal S: I have more details, like… City, I live… Place of birth, occupation, etc.
Monal S: So, all of these are values of a certain person.
Monal S: Certain.
Monal S: person. So we can see that this is the key.
Monal S: Key, as I told you, this is the label. This is what this one is labeled as.
Monal S: And all of these are values of this particular person.
Monal S: Alright? It is for this particular person. I will show you.
Monal S: Now, what we do, this is how we write end dictionary. Let me write… Register.
Monal S: In register also, we do it, right? Everyone say this. In register, how we create it? Here, we create person, and then we create some lines for that person.
Monal S: This is person, this is date of birth, this is phone, this is city, place of birth, and occupation.
Monal S: Understand, you will understand now, okay? Here, if I write person monol.
Monal S: and write all the details. All of these details in its respective row is… does belongs to a person called as Munat. Similarly, let me write Rohit. Whatever name I'm seeing, guys, I'm writing it. Okay?
Monal S: Rohit. Then Preetam.
Monal S: Alright, so this is my register. In this register, if someone asks me tomorrow.
Monal S: Let's check the details of Pritham.
Monal S: Will I be looking Pritham here, here, here, here? No. I know that Preetam is the name of the person, I can directly go to the Preetam and get his details.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: So what I'm using, I'm using the label to access the value of Pritha. This is how we deal in real world, this is what the real register is.
Monal S: a notebook register, not the Python notebook, but the notebook in real world, the paper one, alright? This is what the real register looks like. Similarly, if I want to create a register with
Monal S: list, just for an example. What I have to do, I have to write a variable called as Prithumb.
Monal S: Pritham, and then store the value of Pritham. Similarly, I will create thousands of people.
Monal S: This is not a good idea. I want a structure in which I can just write pre-tham and get the details. I cannot do that with list. So what I will do, I will create a data structure like this, register.
Monal S: And dictionary, we start with curly brackets.
Monal S: List which starts with square bracket, but…
Monal S: Dictionary, we start with curly brackets.
Monal S: Now, what I will do, in this register, this is how we start it, but in this register, what I will do, see this?
Monal S: In this register, I will create the key as Preetam.
Monal S: This is the label. We have created the label, label is done. Now the values of it, this is how we define the values. We can write the details of preterm, like date of birth.
Monal S: Phone… PT… Place of birth, and occupation.
Monal S: And once we are done with the details of Pritham, we can write thousands of details that will belong to Pritham. We will close it.
Monal S: Now, let's suppose I want to add a new person. See this? Key value payer. This is called as key, this is called as its value. So, the format is…
Monal S: What is the syntax?
Monal S: Syntax means, what is the structure of a particular data structure, alright? Or the data type. Syntax is…
Monal S: we write key colon value pair. This is what the syntax of dictionary is, alright? So, we have seen that how to add this pre-thumb. Now, similarly, once pre-thumb is done, we will close the bracket just like a list, and this is done.
Monal S: Now, let's extend this.
Monal S: Let's extend this here.
Monal S: And we'll show you more things.
Monal S: Preetam is done. Now I want to add 4 more people.
Monal S: I want to add for more people. So what I will do, this key-value pair is done, I will add a comma, and I can write start for next person, let's say for Rohit.
Monal S: Rohit is the new key, these are values of Rohit.
Monal S: Again, if I want to add someone, I'm adding Ankit.
Monal S: Ankit is the new key, which is a string, colon, the values of ankith.
Monal S: Close it.
Monal S: Then, let's pick one other name.
Monal S: Okay, Amit.
Monal S: Amit is the key.
Monal S: Then, these are the values of Amit. Once I am adding all the values, I will close the dictionary, and this is my new register R.
Monal S: Done. Now, how to access it? Very simple.
Monal S: I will write R, and here I will write what values I want to access, just like a register. In register, I mentioned that I want to know the details of Pritham, then I will get the value. Similarly, I will write R,
Monal S: And in square bracket, I will write who I want to access, which key I want to access.
Monal S: I want to access Amit. Again, it is case sensitive. Amit.
Monal S: when I write Ahmed, When I use this key of Amit.
Monal S: with the variable R, it will give us the amitz value.
Monal S: Alright? So this is the main concept of dictionary. Guys, don't ask anything other than this. If you're able to understand this, say yes, then I will jump to the more detailed part of dictionary. I'm enabling the chat.
Monal S: Don't say, sir, this method, this method, no. Only talking about this, ask the doubt if you have it here.
Monal S: Start.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Is this part super clear? Why we need it is also very important. Is everyone able to understand this?
Monal S: Guys, whatever I didn't taught, like, tuple or something, don't ask. Tuple will come after dictionary.
Monal S: Alright, now some attributes, yes.
Monal S: Now let me write some attributes.
Monal S: He's… Should… Always be unique.
Monal S: No two key in our dictionary should be same. With all the values have the same structure, it can have same thing.
Monal S: Guys, Sumit, what did I mention?
Monal S: E's should always be unique.
Monal S: duplicate… Values are accepted.
Monal S: Same person can have same value, multiple persons can have the same value, it is totally fine. But keys should always be unique. Right now, a lot of you are not familiar with the concept of hashable.
Monal S: I'm not teaching you hashable right now, but will teach you later, okay? Dictionary uses some internal methods of calling hashes. No two keys should have the same value. See this, no two keys should have the same name.
Monal S: Rhythm cannot be repeated 2 times.
Monal S: it will give you error, okay? It is not accepted.
Monal S: Is this fine?
Monal S: How to get dict value if you don't know the person name? Yes. Pandit Salvan, I will talk about it.
Monal S: Not understand, please repeat, guys, how many of you are not able to understand dictionary?
Monal S: How many of you are not able to understand?
Monal S: One-to-one possible?
Monal S: Okay, see this?
Monal S: Is everyone clear with the concept of register? People who were not able to understood, is this particular concept of register clear?
Monal S: Concept of register.
Monal S: Yes, everyone should have these concepts clear. So here, what we have… Rudra, is this concept of register is not even clear?
Monal S: Guys, register, I'm talking about…
Monal S: I'm talking about registers.
Monal S: Is the concept of registers clear?
Monal S: Please repeat register.
Monal S: See, that's why I don't disable chat.
Monal S: It creates an issue.
Monal S: All right.
Monal S: Ugh.
Monal S: Don't worry, guys, it's totally fine, okay?
Monal S: But listening to some people to disable chat sometimes creates an issue. Enabling it again, like…
Monal S: Why you enable them? Rajvir, am I teaching to only few people?
Monal S: Rajbil?
Monal S: Do you want other people to not learn and then stay? Guys?
Monal S: If you don't know about learning, see this.
Monal S: This is how learning happens. Let me waste some of your time.
Monal S: This is how learning should be.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: By time, you learn more things. This is your time.
Monal S: And this is… more concepts.
Monal S: Learn more concepts. Have everyone see this carefully.
Monal S: learn more concepts. So, it should increase when you put more time.
Monal S: But what will happen, for a lot of people, this is what reality is. Some of you might be able to understand it, some of you might not. But let's suppose in this time, you don't know something. This is where your focus got broken. What will happen?
Monal S: When the time increases, their learning will not increase much.
Monal S: Because… For some reason,
Monal S: Some people can get demotivated, some people might get, okay, my focus is broken now, and I will not read it.
Monal S: Who will be responsible for this?
Monal S: If I don't stop in between. There are a lot of people I know, people just put messages in community, tell that, disable chat, disable chat.
Monal S: Who is going to be responsible? Can someone please give me a name who will be responsible in teaching other people when their focus is broken?
Monal S: Anyone here who can raise hand, I will create a Zoom link for them, they can… Arun, you will be the responsible, you can teach other people.
Monal S: Say yes.
Monal S: Okay, guys, Arun is saying that. How many of you want to learn from Arun? Arun is saying yes. Arun will create a Google Meet and will teach you everything from the broken, so that Arun can learn other things in that time. How many of you want to learn from Arun?
Monal S: Oh, I don't… see, if you just answer yes and no, this is what I will get, right?
Monal S: Alright? So guys, always… see, everyone, don't think that I'm wasting time here. We are here to learn from each other as well. If someone is not learning, then we will pause it. If this is a part of the class, this is also a part of the class that you will get in life. In Udemy, no mentor will discuss that, why people are not able to understand.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Okay, great. Don't worry, I don't… guys.
Monal S: First, remove this concept that I am trying to hurt someone, I'm trying to harm someone.
Monal S: Alright? If you give me some feedback, I will improve. If you give me negative feedback, I will think negatively. What I will do by thinking negatively of you, alright? I'm only here to teach you, and I only want all of you to grow. That's all.
Monal S: Okay? I only want all of you to grow. I'm already in a certain position, I'm only because of myself, my learnings, I'm here to teach as much as I can. That's all. Alright, everyone, guys, I will answer each and everyone's question. Let's first understand the concept of register.
Monal S: Serious, first focus here.
Monal S: Don't focus on chat.
Monal S: Register.
Monal S: again, I am repeating that now my task is… see, my task is different now. Now my task is…
Monal S: I… want to… No down.
Monal S: Details of visitors.
Monal S: That's all. I want to note down details of visitor. What is the best way? Either in a single page, either in a single page.
Monal S: Yes, there is only one way. I want to note down details of a visitor. So what I will do, I will note down their name. Let me keep this one short. Their name, their address.
Monal S: Their name, their address, their phone number.
Monal S: And let's take another cons… another thing like… Verification.
Monal S: ID.
Monal S: That's all.
Monal S: Is this part clear to everyone?
Monal S: I have their name, address, phone number, and ID. This is my register, and I want to take it down. So, this is the only way to do it efficiently. So what I will do here, I will write person name.
Monal S: and their address.
Monal S: I will write someone else's name their address. I will write their address. I will write their address phone number.
Monal S: So, what is the use of this register?
Monal S: What is the use of this register?
Monal S: If I want to know who visited at what time.
Monal S: Alright? I can check, I can check.
Monal S: If I want to know when Monol visited.
Monal S: Do I have to check in the column of address? Do I have to check in these three columns? Tell me.
Monal S: Do I have to check in these three columns for monol? No. We know that monol is the person, and person name is present in… person name is present in what column?
Monal S: Person name is present in what column? Name. So, I will be looking at name.
Monal S: So, by this method, will I be able to access Monol's details very fast, instead of looking at all columns? Yes.
Monal S: This is the only way.
Monal S: Everyone tell me, people who are not able to understand.
Monal S: Is this true or not?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Yes, it's more like an Excel spreadsheet. Now, similarly, I want to store… this is how we store things in our register, in our notebooks. Now, similarly, I have this kind of a problem statement, but I cannot store things in a list.
Monal S: If I have to create a register and list, what I have to do? I will create monol.
Monal S: I will create monol, then monol's…
Monal S: Let's write the details. Nan, Monol's address…
Monal S: phone number, and ID.
Monal S: Now, if thousand peoples will come, I have to create thousands of variables. Yes?
Monal S: I have to create thousands of variables. So here, what is the issue? Here, what is the issue?
Monal S: Lots of variable.
Monal S: Similarly, I can use another thing. Let's say I can create something like register, and in this register, I can use something like this.
Monal S: I have already taught you this, yes?
Monal S: Can I also create a solution like this, everyone?
Monal S: So, in a single register, now I have one list, but I can add multiple people's
Monal S: Thousand of people in the list.
Monal S: So, this solves… List in a dict? Guys, what is this?
Monal S: This solves the problem.
Monal S: but not efficient. Not efficient in the means of? If I have to… if I have to reach to, let's say, Amit. Amit is present in the third one.
Monal S: The third list, but the index is 0, 1, 2. Amit is present in second, 0th list, alright? Not 0.
Monal S: Index number 2 list, alright? Amit is present in here. So what we will do, we have to go inside register, check, check each and every values of list, and then if Amit found in any of them, then we will extract all the values of Amit. See, it is little inefficient. We have to write more code.
Monal S: And there comes a better solution called as dictionary.
Monal S: Dictionary Foundation itself tells that instead of storing values, like all of the values in a single list, why not store values in a key and value pair?
Monal S: key and value payer.
Monal S: Alright? Think of this as your car. This is your car.
Monal S: This is your car.
Monal S: you have… Key of your car.
Monal S: Your key, when you press the button in your key, it will only be applicable to your car, yes or no?
Monal S: It will only be applicable to your car, yes?
Monal S: If I press my key, will it, will it horn, or will it start my neighbor's car?
Monal S: Will it work for neighbor's car? Will my key going to work with my neighbor's car? Others tell me. No.
Monal S: So, if I want to create a separation, why not use a better data structure, which is dictionary? So, what dictionary tells you? Dictionary tells you that key should be unique. So, if something is unique, why not put name here?
Monal S: and all the values of monol, I can write monol date of birth, which is just a string, or I can write another list inside, as a value. So I can write address.
Monal S: I can write address, phone number, and ID of Monol in a list.
Monal S: And this dictionary is done. If I want to add more people, this is key value pair is done. This consists of one value. Once this is done, by adding comma, I can write more people.
Monal S: Amit.
Monal S: Amit is key, so I will use Amit's address, phone number. Let's say Amit does not have ID. I can stop, because this is list.
Monal S: List does not… value should not be same, value should be different, value can be anything. But here you can see…
Monal S: Keys of it should be different.
Monal S: Please cannot be seen. Is everyone clear now?
Monal S: Why we are using dictionary, how to use dictionary, I will… I've not written the code. Code will look similar. People who were not able to understand it before are clear now.
Monal S: Are we clear now?
Monal S: Audit.
Monal S: Great. Okay? So now, let's go to the spectacle. I'm disabling the chat for now. I will again initiate it. If you're not able to understand, I will tell you, but keep your focus here.
Monal S: I will show you guys, I will show you. Say this. Roid, I will answer your question, okay?
Monal S: So, it is already 10.15, after a few… 15-20… after dictionary, we will give break, okay?
Monal S: See this.
Monal S: Now, let's jump to the dictionary.
Monal S: For dictionary, I can start a markdown.
Monal S: Did I disable the chat? Yes. All right. See, everyone.
Monal S: So what I will do, I will create a dictionary called as register. This is one of the very simple examples, and this is a dictionary. You can write whatever you write in between. But if you just write list.
Monal S: If you just write list, it will say there is something error, because dictionary follows what?
Monal S: Dictionary follows what?
Monal S: E colon value. This is the syntax.
Monal S: This is the syntax, alright? So what I will do, I will write… Let's suppose…
Monal S: Rohitney.
Monal S: This is Rohit. Then colon, see this key part is done. Now I will write colon. Now it's time for value. Value, I can write whatever I want. Let's suppose Rohit, date of birth, 12…
Monal S: 12…
Monal S: 2020. I know this is not possible, but I'm just writing it, okay? Rohit, phone number 123456789. Alright, I think this…
Monal S: That's better to wait.
Monal S: Not too old.
Monal S: Better?
Monal S: Rohit ID is A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H. This is Rohit values done. This is Rohit key, Rohit value.
Monal S: Similarly, I can do what? I can enter multiple people, but you can see now it is giving error. Why? Multiple people. Each key value should be separated by comma. So this is one key value.
Monal S: If I want to add another key value, I need to use comma.
Monal S: Okay? Also, you can, if you want, you can write it like this. There is no indentation issue, alright? This is just like list. No indentation. You can write it like this, or press enter to have it better formatted. Now, this time, if I again write Rohit.
Monal S: Everything is fine.
Monal S: It is not giving me error, but let's see…
Monal S: Run. Again, if I print the register to see what values this register contains, it only contains…
Monal S: It only contains this minus 1 980 and some values like this.
Monal S: All right? Okay. See, this one should be string. Sorry.
Monal S: That's why there is some error.
Monal S: Don't forget to write string.
Monal S: Alright, let's run again.
Monal S: It only contains the last value, so it means it is not retaining two values at a time. It is removing the one which has the same key.
Monal S: So, Rohit key got stored in the RAM. When dictionary sees another Rohit, the previous one got removed.
Monal S: So, it does not allow duplicates of the keys. It will… it will give you weird behavior. If I write Rohit.
Monal S: Or Rohit, R-O-H-I-T-H.
Monal S: and then write it. Then we will see both the Rohit. This is Rohit with the one key, this is Rohit with another key.
Monal S: Alright? Similarly, Keys can be anything. One can be a key.
Monal S: One can be a key, it is totally up to me. I'm giving you a concept of register to understand when to use what. So, I will not use 1, 2, 3, anything weird. I will use, let's suppose, monol.
Monal S: And for monol, I don't have list.
Monal S: For monol, I don't have list. For monol, I only have false. Monal did not provide anything. I could have written inside the list, but it is totally up to developer what they want to write. So here, this is also acceptable. As I mentioned, value can be anything.
Monal S: But the key should be either string, what did I mention?
Monal S: Keys should be only… see this?
Monal S: Keys should be string, numbers, or tuples, which we are going to see. Tuples is the next data type. Done.
Monal S: So, Rohit, Rohit, Mono. Let's run it.
Monal S: So, let's see this. This is Rohit.
Monal S: and Rohit's value.
Monal S: After comma, this is Rohit.
Monal S: and Rohit values.
Monal S: And last, monol and monol values, that is just false.
Monal S: If you have any question in this part, then tell me all how to iterate over it, how to access the value, I will talk about later. Don't ask caution on that.
Monal S: Alright, guys?
Monal S: Is this part clear to everyone?
Monal S: Our date of birth allowed before writing as a string, what type of data it was. No, that was some kind of error. Don't worry. This is not how we write it.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: That was minus 1980.
Monal S: Are you clear?
Monal S: When I've written something like this, it was 12 minus 12 minus 1980. Kishore.
Monal S: Guys, when I've written without string, Python will consider it as operation 12 minus 12 minus 1980.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: operation.
Monal S: If same name data need, how to add in the list?
Monal S: No, guys, two people… okay, in register, if you think, okay, everyone, this is now your logic.
Monal S: If you think in register, if you think in register, two people can have the same name.
Monal S: It is totally possible. Then, will you use their name to check their values?
Monal S: Will you use their name to check their values? No.
Monal S: You will use unique ID, you will say, this person phone number I have, I want to check their values.
Monal S: So, guys, in real world, when something duplicates, that's why people get ID. That's why in your government ID, you have given ID, because two people have given name. So, if I'm trying to create a government system.
Monal S: If I'm trying to create a government system.
Monal S: end dictionary, I will use ID number. See, this is marked down, that's why it is creating an error.
Monal S: Guys, we have to think like a developer. We will start with ID number and then store their details.
Monal S: Whatever their names are. Then, another ID will have its own details.
Monal S: Does this make sense, everyone?
Monal S: Is this making sense?
Monal S: This is how we design as a developer. Yes, we should know what will not work, but in the real world, we rarely work with names as the main key.
Monal S: We work with some kind of an ID, some kind of a value, to work it like this.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Is everyone able to relate with the real world as well?
Monal S: Anyone with a new name? David.
Monal S: Anyone with a new name, Surya.
Monal S: To hell, if keys are same hash value.
Monal S: Then it will work like Ruid and Ruid.
Monal S: 12, are we clear?
Monal S: Since it is printing with single codes, guys, it is printing single codes because it is just output. Python just wants a way to tell us that this is a string.
Monal S: This is print.
Monal S: Once you understand double quotes and single quotes can be used for both strings.
Monal S: Can we use values without list, Sudarshan? Can we use values without list?
Monal S: Does this answer your question, Sudarshan?
Monal S: Others, anyone has more doubt here. Whatever I taught you, anyone has more doubt, at least just in this part.
Monal S: Just in this part.
Monal S: Dict will have latest key if hash is same, yes.
Monal S: Guys, what can be the data type of values?
Monal S: What can be the data type of values?
Monal S: Can you please read, everyone?
Monal S: Correct.
Monal S: Anything.
Monal S: See, I… I'm not proving anything, I'm just coming it back so that once this class is over, you should know where to find answers. Answers are in our notes everywhere.
Monal S: Now tell me, key can be any data type, Tanme?
Monal S: Key can be any data type.
Monal S: Tanme, correct, Julie.
Monal S: Tanme… Guys, Tanay is saying yes, maybe. Tanay, I have written 3.
Monal S: Does it include TanMay Boolean here?
Monal S: Guys, first of all, let me give you 2 minutes to read everything.
Monal S: Everyone, read this, I'm giving you one minute. Read this, fast.
Monal S: Again, I'm seeing some lack of con- concentration.
Monal S: Panktisar, what is your issue? Can you please reply again?
Monal S: Aslam, actually, I'm giving topics, but for some reason, team is not able to add them directly, because the names will be higher. Because every time I'm giving topics, but let me give, better things, okay? Maybe in the…
Monal S: Pankti, as I mentioned, right, deletion, updation, I will teach, I've not taught yet.
Monal S: Guys, anything regarding how to use list, how to get the values, I've not taught yet. But for now, focus here. Everyone, will it be better if I paste what things which we are going to learn, and
Monal S: And the announcement as well, so you guys can check it before coming to class.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Fine.
Monal S: When we will start machine learning.
Monal S: I will all… I'm all… I am also adding that FAQ, because someone has asked, that is a great question, that what is the estimate time?
Monal S: For of the previous class, I cannot estimate for this class. Then I will share that FAQ here as well, okay? Don't worry, that is on my plan.
Monal S: Yes, guys, I will do that. I am here to help you.
Monal S: Don't see me as your enemy.
Monal S: Okay, I'm here to help everyone.
Monal S: Alright, so let's get started.
Monal S: Now, let me talk about the other parts.
Monal S: Yes, Praveen, I will give you.
Monal S: That is on my list.
Monal S: Guys, I am disabling the chat, let's focus on the next part of the dictionary, else we will be stuck in list and dictionary forever.
Monal S: This thing only comes with practice, trust me.
Monal S: Okay? Now let's talk about dictionary, how to access it.
Monal S: Dictionary.
Monal S: Dictionary. This is… I've just written. Dictionary comes with its own methods, just like list, append, and something. Here we have keys.
Monal S: When we write dot keys, we get… all the keys… in our dictionary.
Monal S: When we use dot values, we get all the values in a dictionary.
Monal S: All the values in a dictionary.
Monal S: There is something called as .get.
Monal S: Okay? There is something called as .get to get the value. I will teach you that as well, okay? But how to access things? .get here we provide
Monal S: Provide key to get value.
Monal S: So, if I want to retrieve something, if this is my dictionary, let's run it, and let me zoom in. If this is my dictionary, and I want to retrieve all the details of person 101, or ID101, as I mentioned, I can use the dictionary, then let's mention GET.
Monal S: Inget of what?
Monal S: 101.
Monal S: Clear. Similarly, instead of GET, I can also use a different fashion, similar like a list, but make sure that your data type is dictionary, then only it will work. If you mention 101,
Monal S: What it will do, it will check it is a dictionary or not. If it is a dictionary, then whatever we are passing, it will consider it as a key. Is 101 matching with any of this?
Monal S: Yes, we have 101, so get the value. So either use GET, or this.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: But GET also gives you more things, I will tell you. So, let's suppose I want to access ID number 105.
Monal S: Is it giving you anything? No, it does not even give you error, just like a list. List gives you error, index out of bound.
Monal S: But here, when I'm trying to access 105, which does not exist, you can see, it is not giving me anything, because this is a method, it is used for that. In coding, when we get error, our system breaks.
Monal S: Our coding flow breaks.
Monal S: So dictionary, when we use GET, it is not breaking the code. Even though it is not giving you any output, it is not breaking. But if I use this kind of a method, which is a list kind of structure, if I use 105, it will give me that this key does not present, key error, 105 does not present.
Monal S: So, GET is more stable in terms of the output. If something does not
Monal S: present in the list, it will not give you an error. It will give you empty output. There is no output.
Monal S: But when you use this fashion of accessing the value, it will give you an error if the element is not present in the dictionary. Both of them have their pros and cons. In GET, if something is not present, you can also tell that
Monal S: If it is not present, what output should you provide? A by default, by default is nothing.
Monal S: If 105 is not present, what should be the output? Nothing.
Monal S: We can write, if something is not present, by default is, just tell user, Value not present.
Monal S: Value not present.
Monal S: So, if 105 is not present, it will give you value not present. Think of this as, like, if and else.
Monal S: If 105 is present, Get the value of 105.
Monal S: Else, print value not present.
Monal S: See this? If I just write 101, it will go and check if 101 is present. The answer is 101 is present. It will get the value. So we will see value here when I run it.
Monal S: Value.
Monal S: If 101 was not present, similar like 110, because 110 is not present, this condition will be false, and it will go to the else condition, that is value not present.
Monal S: value not present. Just giving you an option, okay? How to understand all of this.
Monal S: I hope everyone is clear here. Using GET,
Monal S: Using GET, alright? So there are two ways to access it, either by the key, using the list style, or use the method of the dictionary, that is GET. So there are two ways to do it.
Monal S: Alright? So now let's talk about those values. So if I say government SYS, and I will use the next method, that is keys.
Monal S: I will use KEYS.
Monal S: It will give us all the keys present in the dictionary.
Monal S: It will give you all the keys present in the dictionary. Similarly, you can use values.
Monal S: it will give you all the values. You can see monol was one of the value, Amit, dahwal, Surya. But guys, in Python, when we have multi… series, understand.
Monal S: In Python, when we have multiple values, can we store all of them in a variable? No. To store a group of values, I need to enclose them in a list.
Monal S: Similarly, when I use dot values, dot keys, how many keys I have? I have 101, 102, 103, 104.
Monal S: I cannot break the coding language. When I'm saying dot keys, these are the keys, yes, but how to return it? Because a variable cannot hold all the four values.
Monal S: So, I will enclose them in a list, and then…
Monal S: return it. So you can see, when I write government keys.
Monal S: You can see 104 is coming, but it is coming in a list, because we need to group them. Otherwise, how Python is going to give us that value?
Monal S: Similar for values. When we see values, monol is a value with a square bracket, that is a list. This is a value, this is another value, this is another value, this is another value. Similarly, if I have multiple lists.
Monal S: If I have multiple lists, as my output.
Monal S: Can I store all of them in a single variable? No.
Monal S: I made one more list which enclosed all of this output. So that's why I am seeing
Monal S: two square bracket here. One is…
Monal S: Just to enclose all this 4 lists from the values.
Monal S: I'm disabling the chat. So, is everyone able to understand the behavior? Everything is very simple, guys. Is everyone able to understand the behavior?
Monal S: Very simple behavior.
Monal S: Please show the register is starting, this is the register is starting, this is the government system. We are working on government system. Yes?
Monal S: Very simple, guys.
Monal S: The more you practice with it.
Monal S: Just to confirm, we typecast this into list.
Monal S: And then, accordingly, use as needed.
Monal S: Yes, Karthik. I will show you that. Or you can just iterate and it will work.
Monal S: I can't see the code, that's why. Guys, it's fine. But, I can paste the code
Monal S: But I don't have a lot of code, it's fine.
Monal S: This is what I'm using, this is what I'm doing.
Monal S: How will you rename keys? Those are value greater than 5000? We don't rename keys, we remove it.
Monal S: Alright? We don't rename keys.
Monal S: Mantesh.
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: So, now see the next part. Guys, when I'm returning something.
Monal S: Is it a data type list?
Monal S: Someone is asking why two brackets?
Monal S: Guys, I just now explained why two brackets. Literally.
Monal S: Because of Instagram, our focus is all over the place.
Monal S: Guys, everyone, I will just talk about this one time, then I will give the break.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: If I have 1, 2, 3, 4.
Monal S: Tell me, can I store this in a variable A?
Monal S: Tell me, can I store this in a variable A? All four values in a variable A.
Monal S: Which was the data type we have utilized, which can store multiple values?
Monal S: Yes, this is the answer of dot keys.
Monal S: But programmatically speaking, when I have to store multiple things, I will do what?
Monal S: I will do what? If I have multiple values, I need to enclose them in some kind of a bracket, then I will return. So that's why dot keys, when I mention, it is returning with a square bracket. Done.
Monal S: Now, what are the values? My values is monol with a square bracket. It is a value, don't forget list. This is a list, list, list, list.
Monal S: Now, if I have multiple lists as the answer.
Monal S: Can I store them in A again?
Monal S: Multiple lists in a single.
Monal S: Again, what we need to store all of this multiple… don't think of this as list. It is a value itself. All of them, indeed, is a list, is a value. So we need to enclose them in another square bracket. So this is the value, this is the answer which we are getting from the value.
Monal S: But… to contain it.
Monal S: This dictionary and Python already handle it for us and package them in a one outer layer of square bracket.
Monal S: Why the keys are coming inside dicked keys? Yes.
Monal S: Alright, is this part clear to everyone?
Monal S: Done.
Monal S: Yes, correct.
Monal S: Peroz.
Monal S: Sir, cannot copy, guys, you will not be able to copy, don't copy it, don't focus on coding right now.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: How to access the Notion link? How many of you know how to access the Notion link?
Monal S: Guys, before going on break again.
Monal S: Because some of people… some people here tells me that I'm too… Annoyed.
Monal S: Right? I get annoyed very fast. I'm getting annoyed very fast because I already repeated 5 times, but see this. I don't have Notion Link.
Monal S: Did I share Notion link in chat?
Monal S: Did I share Notion link in chat ever? I've never shared it.
Monal S: I have never… guys, see this.
Monal S: There is a reason for getting annoyed, correct, Pratik?
Monal S: A really awesome session. Guys, are you enjoying the class? Apart from all of these annoyed things, okay, which will come and go. Are you enjoying class? People who are annoyed, people are not annoyed with me, others.
Monal S: See, this way of learning, we need to understand. How I'm teaching you, how you guys are learning, enjoying? Great.
Monal S: Let's wait, guys.
Monal S: Ugh.
Monal S: I think a lot of you are accessing, even… I cannot access the website.
Monal S: Others, will you be able to help if someone needs access of the Notion?
Monal S: See, I'm telling you. This is Ultimate… guys, again, please stop chat and see this. This is Ultimate Data Science. If you click on it, you will see this screen. I have added one miscellaneous section. Here, only I have written
Monal S: Mentor One Reference. Click on it, it will open this page. Here is the link. You can open in a new tab, you can open it in… currently, I'm opening because I want to show you that it works without login.
Monal S: So, this is what we have.
Monal S: Is Notion looking good? Guys, is this Notion looking good?
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: So, whatever FAQs you guys want me to add, please also tell me in the community. So, if you feel… if you personally feel like this question is getting repeated multiple times, I will add those things here.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: So, guys, I listened to your feedback, don't worry.
Monal S: this… someone wanted everything in a single place, you can see, if you open any of the Drive link, it will open a drive link, and you can see this is 21's assignment. Just download it.
Monal S: Don't worry about Notion, just worry about this link, Data Science 2. And please don't forget to read whatever I've written, it is there for some purpose. This will answer all of your questions already.
Monal S: Alright, so let me close it, we don't require it. And let's go on a break. Yes, guys, break is fine.
Monal S: Guys, any doubts on that, we will cover later, don't worry, I'm here.
Monal S: Can you please tell Chris's AI project new course, do we get any coupon? Guys, that project is not for course, that is a whole new product.
Monal S: Just like this data science is a new batch, that product is a…
Monal S: Different. Guys, it will work, don't worry. Lot of you are accessing, that's why it is creating issue. It might be possible that Notion will break, I'm using just a free version. 15 minutes break is fine.
Monal S: Correct?
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: So, let's start, and I will see you after 15 minutes, guys.
Monal S: Code is just running, again, close the VS Code and run out again.
Monal S: Alright, 20 minutes for now. For today, 20 minutes.
Monal S: See you guys, bye-bye.
Monal S: Oh, sorry, I was on mute. No one is telling me I was on mute. Someone tell. Krishna. Hey guys, I hope everyone is back, done with their brunch, breakfast, lunch, dinner, yes?
Monal S: Well, please ask that at the end, alright? I will answer that. Okay, yes, back? Great.
Monal S: Feeling energetic now?
Monal S: Sometimes we need pause to learn more things, and this is that part. Still, no audio, guys.
Monal S: Audio, yes, David?
Monal S: Guys, don't worry about website for now, let's look at website later, alright?
Monal S: Loving the session, that's great, guys, that's great.
Monal S: Okay, so we are done with lists and dictionaries, and guys, these are…
Monal S: And guys, tell me whether list… without even working with it, tell me whether list and dictionaries are iterable or not.
Monal S: My messages are never seen, Abhishek. I just saw your messages.
Monal S: Nice.
Monal S: I keep telling you again and again that
Monal S: If I'm not able to see someone's messages, it is because I'm not able to see, because there are a lot of messages, alright? Don't worry.
Monal S: Yes, because it holds a lot of values, they are iterable, okay? We will talk about those iterable when we again go to the loop, but for now, let's complete these data types.
Monal S: Problem on my end. Yes, David, there is problem on your end, okay? So now, let's jump to the next part. We have understood that
Monal S: what is this values, what we'll be able to do with it. And guys, yes, I was talking about this dictionary keys. The output.
Monal S: See, my question is never answered, how many sessions Python will be covered? Shazad, did I never answer this? How many sessions Python will be covered?
Monal S: I told you, I will be telling you that. I don't have the exact number.
Monal S: Because that was the answer. Shazad, are you clear?
Monal S: I will give you an approximate in the FAQ, I will check that today.
Monal S: Yes, Rahul. Alright, guys, I are turning, the chat off.
Monal S: Guys, theme of VS Code, I will tell again, okay? Sure.
Monal S: Disabled. Okay, so we have seen that, a new kind of a data type called as dict keys, dict values, which we don't know. Well, actually, these values are a different class. Class we have seen, right? When I do… when I do…
Monal S: type of 1, I see int. Similarly, when I'm doing type of… these values, when I'm printing, it is automatically giving us its type. It is a different type which we have not, but these are relevant to dictionaries, not for us. Currently, if I want to work with it, you can see that there is a list inside.
Monal S: If I use government sys.values, and then do typecasting to list, We can see lists.
Monal S: Because you can see, there is a square bracket. If a square bracket was not inside, we will not be able to convert it to list.
Monal S: So, make sure that we can do this as well. Now, this is iterable.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: I told you in the for loop, now if I copy and paste this.
Monal S: Say this, now if I copy and paste this and write in for loop, for I in list of this, let's print I.
Monal S: Because it's a triple, it works.
Monal S: Yes, it works. Similarly, I can copy and paste the value part. Guys, don't say how it works, I already told you. So…
Monal S: instead of this, because this one is providing me the final list. If I print it.
Monal S: I will see Monolami at Dawal Surya. So take your time, pick a copy at no, pen and paper, and then check what values it is coming one by one.
Monal S: Alright? Done. So, don't worry, in the for loop again, I will talk about it, but it is also your duty to explore things, alright? One good thing that I'm seeing from few people, only few people, they are asking, but I'm not directly answering it. So, some people are asking, sir,
Monal S: Can. We. Have.
Monal S: list as… keys in dictionary. Well, if I talk about it, let's see…
Monal S: If I have dictionary, A is equal to something, and here I will type 1, 2, 3.
Monal S: And let's say hello.
Monal S: Well, did we got the answer? Yes. So what I want from everyone, alright, what I want from everyone, it is good to have these questions in your mind.
Monal S: Alright? It tells that you are eager, you are asking questions in the right direction, but I've already determined that list will not work, so that part you need to focus on, but always make sure that you are asking more and more questions.
Monal S: And what I want for more questions is for you to try. You should do lot of permutation and combination once the class is over.
Monal S: Play with the core.
Monal S: Play with the code, understand what works, what does not work. If some error you are getting, ask ChatGPT, Gemini, or search on Google that why it does not work. Currently, I told you what is… I didn't told you what is hash.
Monal S: Alright? What is it used for? It is a part of computer science, which we will learn later, but if I introduce today, the whole class will be gone.
Monal S: So, some things I'm not introducing at this stage because of the current level we are in, but
Monal S: If someone wants to go in more depth, they can do permutation and combination, get their answers fast by looking at the Google, because a developer will not be a developer if they don't have more questions, and also, they are not able to understand the solution which other developers are telling on the internet.
Monal S: Alright? Is this part clear? Yes, I'm expecting everyone to say yes, chat is disabled. So this is a very good thing, and I will suggest everyone to ask more and more questions. Note those questions down.
Monal S: Alright? Note those questions down. If time comes, I will answer. If today we don't have time, then we will answer it later. But a lot of the things, when we start itself, I'm already writing it down.
Monal S: everything, a lot of the questions were already present, but it's fine, okay? So, dictionary is done. We have seen that anything is iterable if it consists of multiple values.
Monal S: In a group kind of thing, and we are able to iterate over it. How to understand it better, and other things, we'll talk about that later. But today, the next part, which we are talking about.
Monal S: is called as next data type is called as tuple. Okay? Tuple. T-U-P-L-E. So, let me copy that text part, which we write.
Monal S: We are doing a lot of experiment.
Monal S: Tupa.
Monal S: So let me write…
Monal S: List and dictionary are the main ones, this is a little different, okay? This one is called as the immutable
Monal S: This is immutable data type.
Monal S: Alright, now I will talk about what is mutable and immutable before going and, let me erase all of it.
Monal S: So let's first cover the topic itself that is called as mutable and immutable.
Monal S: So guys, data types are divided into further categories, that is called as mutable and immutable. If you check just from the meaning of the word mutable, not even in Python, what is mutable? Mutable means something that can be changed.
Monal S: something that can be changed. So, here it means changes are allowed, or changes are expected. Immutable means?
Monal S: We cannot mutate it.
Monal S: Changes are not allowed. I'm just tuning the main definition down. Changes are not allowed.
Monal S: We have seen that in list, we have seen that in list, when we create a list, we can append
Monal S: We can append, we can pop. Right? So what we are doing… what we are doing…
Monal S: asking you to answer in your head, because you cannot type, right? List, when we are talking about append and pop, we are…
Monal S: Mute,
Monal S: We are changing the list itself. We are adding value, we are popping the value out. So what we are doing.
Monal S: List is a mutable data type.
Monal S: List is what? A mutable data type. So, it is good when you want to add something or remove something. Then, why we even have tuple? Why do we even require a data type which is not mutable?
Monal S: That is, immutable. So, this is used to store data that should not change.
Monal S: data that… to not change.
Monal S: Okay? Think of it as, like, your ID.
Monal S: Your ID is one of those data types which even the government employee, someone who's sitting on the computer who has access to edit things, they should not be able to mutate your things. So, data that should not change. One of the examples is ID, okay? There is concept of data integrity.
Monal S: Alright? Data integrity, it means that data should not be overridden, data should not be changed. So, let me remove this jargon, but it means that
Monal S: It prevents…
Monal S: Accidental… cases where… Data can be… over return.
Monal S: We don't want that, so it even removes those cases. In list, we can, yes, we can change any value, we can append any value, we can do whatever we want. But here, we will not be able to do it. I will tell you in list how it is possible. So let's go to the list section where we had list, where we have list.
Monal S: Let's see… yeah, this is dictionary, and I think I have not written list here.
Monal S: In list. I told you how to access things, but there is another concept of the list. Yes, so this is our current list, which contains Python 10 machine learning. So currently, if you see in index 0, we have Python. But here, if I mention index 0,
Monal S: and I want to add… Python v2.0, a new string. What will happen?
Monal S: This new value… this is a new value, again, I told you, in Python, the flow goes from top to bottom.
Monal S: Right to left.
Monal S: So, write value is going to L of 0. L of 0 is nothing but Python, so it will be replaced. So this is how you can replace the value as well. So, if I write L
Monal S: you can see that value got replaced. Again, just a simple variable kind of a thing, but with Python index. But in tuple, you will not be able to do it, alright? In tuple, you will not be able to do it, so it prevents accidental cases.
Monal S: Again, it accepts It accepts anything. Anything means anything.
Monal S: So guys, I hope everyone is focusing on this particular part, because this is where we are getting the most of the question. What data type it accepts? It accepts any kind of a data type. What is the limitation?
Monal S: Well, the limitation is its advantage, that data should not change. So, limitation is, we cannot have append kind of a method, we cannot have pop kind of a method present here.
Monal S: Or… no reassignment. What is reassignment? Assigning the value, we cannot reassign any value again.
Monal S: Reassignment.
Monal S: after creation.
Monal S: Alright? So, these are for few things like that. So, again, to create a tuple, it is very simple. You just mention, let's suppose your date of birth is one of those tuples. So, you will write date of birth.
Monal S: as a variable, and here you use… in list, we use square bracket. In dictionary, we use curly braces. Here, we use simple parenthesis.
Monal S: Alright? And inside it, we write value. So, date of birth, we can write something like 10th, let's say, March.
Monal S: And let's say, 19… 20.
Monal S: No one is that old here, right? So, here you can see element 1, element 2, element 3, enclosed by these brackets which we are able to see. So, this is not mutable, you will not be able to change any value. So, if you try to use it, if you try to change the value of it.
Monal S: something like the zeroth index I want to use.
Monal S: The 0th index, I want to update it to value of 2, it will throw you an error.
Monal S: Right? It will throw in an error. Where else you can use it? You can use it for the coordinates. Let's suppose…
Monal S: Bangalore has some coordinates. Obviously, Bangalore has some coordinates, but not sure what exactly that points will be. But it will be, let's suppose, X dot 1289 comma Y dot 8329.
Monal S: So do we think that coordinates of a place can be changed? No. Coordinates of the place should never be changed, right? So what, in those cases, we will make it as a tuple.
Monal S: Instead of a dictionary and… Instead of a dictionary and a list.
Monal S: not list… oh, this cross looks like X, so let's not even write it. So this is where we will… where we will use tuple. So let's see that. Let me write tuple.
Monal S: Too big?
Monal S: Again, let me create the same thing, date of birth, with the… with these brackets, and then I will write 10…
Monal S: That's right. Fab.
Monal S: None right.
Monal S: 1920. Okay?
Monal S: Done. If you want to check the type, you can just print the type, it will show you tuple. If you print it, it will show you, it is a class called tuple.
Monal S: Yes, everyone is familiar with that, and if you just print it.
Monal S: Printed DOB, which is a tuple, it will look like this. And if you try to access some element, yes, element is accessible, but let's try to update it.
Monal S: You cannot update a tuple.
Monal S: tuple object does not support… it does not even support item assignments. So, we should be creating tuple only when we feel like, that value should not be changed. Now, let's suppose I want to create this different value. I want to create some persons, like.
Monal S: Let's see. Okay.
Monal S: This might confuse some of the people, but I am creating a better register, register V2, and now everyone see this carefully, don't try to write anything, snap, or click anything, alright? See this. I am creating ID of person 101.
Monal S: Key can be string, number, or tuple. That part is done.
Monal S: Now, what I want is, as I mentioned, value can be anything. Value can be anything. Anything what we have learned till now, you have learned integer, float, string, boolean.
Monal S: We have also learned list dictionary… Tuple. Yes?
Monal S: So, if dictionary can be one of these values, I can also write another dictionary inside it as a value.
Monal S: Now, inside dictionary, I can write what is name of the person? Name is monol.
Monal S: Well, I can change my name, but I cannot change my date of birth. So I will write date of birth.
Monal S: And then…
Monal S: What is the best data type here which we have seen for date of birth? Let's create a tuple.
Monal S: And then we will say the same thing.
Monal S: 10, FEB1920.
Monal S: Tuple created, but make sure that, again, you're… think of… remove everything from here. Just think that we are writing a dictionary. Simple dictionary, just think that we are writing a simple dictionary, or you can do the same thing. Cut it here, and just create dictionary like you create.
Monal S: Just create simple dictionary like you always do. Alright? So, name.
Monal S: I am creating as monol, date of birth is a tuple, then let's say… Phone number.
Monal S: Alright? And this time, I want to make it as a string, so I will write plus 91, then 111111111. Alright? Done. Now, this is a dictionary, which contains a value. I can cut, and instead of… key already present, instead of value, I can write this whole thing.
Monal S: Done.
Monal S: So this is… now you can also format it, whatever you like, whatever looks good to you. So I want to format it like this.
Monal S: I personally feel that This here is more…
Monal S: Clear, okay? This is 101, it's values. Similarly, now, if I want to add more people, what I will do, key is done, value is done, I will enter a comma, and I can enter a new person key and value.
Monal S: So you can see, now it is 102, and again, a new dictionary. This time, this will be Ashish.
Monal S: Alright? Ashes… Let's make Ashish more like a human.
Monal S: Okay? Not like a vampire.
Monal S: And this is 1990, then Ashish's phone number, Ashish's this one.
Monal S: Press Enter. So, this is register V2, a more advanced version. Now, if I want to access someone, I will say, register V2, get me an ID of 101.
Monal S: Yes, I got all the details. I will not be able to change the details, but I will tell you later how to work with dictionaries, how to update these values as well, alright? So…
Monal S: Forget about dictionaries, our main goal was to… where are we going to utilize it?
Monal S: So, that's all. That's all tuple is. Now, I'm disabling the chat, enabling the chat, and I hope everyone understood it. Yes, guys?
Monal S: Is everyone clear with the basic concept of what tuple is?
Monal S: What tuple is?
Monal S: Sure, yeah, class is something that is different. Does tuple work in array, work like array in C? But here, you can see we have multiple values.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: You guys see this? Naming convention I kept a string, or number. All of them are following. Is everyone able to understand this hierarchy I'm creating?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand this hierarchy I'm creating? Everyone.
Monal S: Very simple. I made it simple.
Monal S: Guys, you can create a very complex data structure just by using it. How to add a single element in a tuple? If single element, then remove everything, it will be a tuple.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Date of birth is the only tuple. Can you please explain this example? Again, it is a little confusing. Sakar, I will suggest to you to understand it one by one, depth by depth, see.
Monal S: Again, everyone, this… I know it looks complicated, I told you at the start, right? I'm again copying and pasting it here to everyone.
Monal S: And, how to access code for practice later.
Monal S: Dinesh will talk about it, okay?
Monal S: Maybe you're new to the class?
Monal S: Alright, so, see, again, everyone, because I have written a lot of things, that's why it gets confusing and confusing. So, first of all.
Monal S: Is this part looks clear to everyone?
Monal S: Everyone who was not able to understand or looks confusing. Is this part clear to everyone?
Monal S: Yes, this is as simple as a dictionary can get.
Monal S: Dictionary is nothing but, again, it can be valued, it can be saved in a variable. So this is a value itself. So I will cut it.
Monal S: And you can see that in dictionary, what we do, we write it keys. So if this is my key, value can be anything, I can paste that value which I created before.
Monal S: See this? I'm just formatting. Formatting will not change how the, this one will work like.
Monal S: So, 101 is the key.
Monal S: And this is the key value which is a part of dictionary, so I have written inside a dictionary here a key and value. There should be a value here.
Monal S: There should be a value here. Instead of this value, you can paste another dictionary.
Monal S: This is again a value. If you want, you can again write… Another dictionary.
Monal S: I will say first name.
Monal S: And here I will write last name.
Monal S: This is also a dictionary.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand? Any value can be any data type. It's totally up to you what you want to create further.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: So guys, don't worry, this requires little practice. It's a little bit tricky at the start to see all of this code in a single place, but if you start to break things down, first, copy.
Monal S: Break it down.
Monal S: First copy, break it down.
Monal S: this is served as a value, just like we were learning this part, right? If A is equals to 2, then when we print A, what does? Python is going to get things from the memory, A will be replaced by 2, then we print it. In a similar fashion, I would suggest all of you that whenever we get some kind of a value like this.
Monal S: First, try to understand from the very basic data structure. Divide everything.
Monal S: This is one value.
Monal S: This is the key.
Monal S: This is key value. This is another key value, this is another key value. When we have more of the same data type, the same concept we have learned, when we have more of the data type, if I have 1, 2, 3, 4, I cannot save into A. That's why I'm saving into a
Monal S: List.
Monal S: Alright, that's great. Now, when I have more key-value pairs separated by comma.
Monal S: Separated by comma. Then, I can store into a list.
Monal S: But if all of this key value belong to a person, if all of these values belong to a person, then…
Monal S: Then, what I will do, I will create a key.
Monal S: And in value, I will store…
Monal S: I will store in a list all of them as these values.
Monal S: Similarly, what I've done here, you can see this is one, or inside a dictionary, I have, again, more key values, key values. Whatever you want to do, you guys can decide it.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: It seems the key of a dictionary cannot be changed, it is behaving like a tuple.
Monal S: Key of a dictionary kind of… guys, where is key of dictionary?
Monal S: This is number, this is here.
Monal S: Please hide, yes. Better now?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: So, now, because this is dictionary, now things are getting complex, I will tell you how to access few things. Everyone will… for everyone, focus on the screen now. Even if you are not able to complete some part of it, we want to be master of whatever we are learning.
Monal S: Okay? So I'm disabling the chat now. Guys, you can do anything you want, first try, whatever works, what does not.
Monal S: Alright, disable it.
Monal S: 1, 2, 3, 4. Everyone, please focus, I'm not going to repeat this again. I'm going very slow.
Monal S: If I want to access 3,
Monal S: And this list is called as L.
Monal S: I will first check what is the index. 0, 1, 2, 3. So, to access 3, I will write L of 2, which will give me 3. I hope this part is clear.
Monal S: Guess?
Monal S: Now let's go to L2, a new variable that is version 2.
Monal S: This time, it holds 1, 2, 3, 4.
Monal S: 5, 6, 7, 8. Here we can see, we have one list, we have another list. When we have two lists, what we need to do?
Monal S: We need to enclose them in a bigger thing which can hold multiple things. It can be a dictionary, it can be a list, but if I have to enclose all of them in a dictionary, then I have to write its own key-value pair, which is a different thing. The simplest solution is…
Monal S: Enclose them in another list.
Monal S: So this is level 1 list.
Monal S: This is Level 1 now.
Monal S: I will consider both of them as level 2.
Monal S: Just suppose this is in depth. So, I have one big box. Inside that box, I have two. This one box, I'm calling it as level 1. These two inner boxes, I'm calling it as level 2.
Monal S: Alright? So, in level 1, in Level 1, how many elements we have? In Level 1, I have 2 elements.
Monal S: So, if I want to access 8, let's suppose my target is to access 8.
Monal S: Okay, my target is to access 8. Let's see how do we get there. First, we will go to level 1.
Monal S: L2 is our variable.
Monal S: In level 1, I have two values, 1 and 2. What will be the index of that? Index of this is going to be 0, index of this is going to be 1, because index starts from 0.
Monal S: And in which And in which list, I have my 8,
Monal S: Is it present in 0, or is it present in 1?
Monal S: Again, I'm repeating, I have to access 8, and I can see that 8 is not present inside the first inner list, but it is present inside the second. What is the index of second list? If this is 0, this will be 1. So in L2, I will access 1.
Monal S: When I access index 1, it will give me what? It will give me 5, 6, 7, 8. Guys, am I enabling the chat? Only say whether this is clear or not. Don't ask anything else.
Monal S: Done. Are we able to understand this very clear?
Monal S: Great. Awesome.
Monal S: Everyone said yes.
Monal S: Can't be more clear.
Monal S: Please miss the context.
Monal S: What should I do then? What should I do now? Tell me.
Monal S: Alright, guys, I'm saying that, is this part super clear?
Monal S: that… I want to access aid.
Monal S: And… how should I access aid, then?
Monal S: Inside my Level 1, I have two lists.
Monal S: L2 is a list which contains multiple lists inside it. I want to access L2, and inside it, we have two. So if I access the index 1, I will get the inner list, alright? So now I am disabling the check.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Now that this value gives me inner list, I have to access what?
Monal S: I have to access it. Think of this as, like, the new variable.
Monal S: Think of this as, like, the new variable, just for an example. Let's suppose this L2 is nothing but A.
Monal S: This whole thing is nothing but A. If A is equals to 5, 6, 7, 8, how do we access 8? There are multiple ways.
Monal S: A of minus 1 will give us 8. Yes? Minus 1, minus 2, minus 3, minus 4.
Monal S: What else we can do?
Monal S: A of, in this direction, A of 3 also gives us 8.
Monal S: In reality, do we have A?
Monal S: In reality, we don't have A. So the final answer will be… final answer will be… L of 2…
Monal S: Of 1, which was giving us this list, we want to access.
Monal S: Minus 1, this whole thing was 8, minus 1. L of 2 of 1, which was, again, this whole list, we want to access what element?
Monal S: Third.
Monal S: Three.
Monal S: This gives you 8, this gives you 8.
Monal S: Now tell me, again, I am enabling, is this part clear? How to access things inside something?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Very simple. Guys, it cannot be slower than this.
Monal S: Yes, correct?
Monal S: Now I will tell you the code. Don't worry, guys, I will tell you the code.
Monal S: Guys, one by one.
Monal S: think in terms of how Python will break it. If I write something like this… see, if I write something like this…
Monal S: What does it even mean? Python will try to check this is double list.
Monal S: If I use it, what does it even mean?
Monal S: Python either uses index like this, but it does not uses a combined index like this.
Monal S: So it will never happen.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: This will give you a different list.
Monal S: In this answer, you will provide a new list.
Monal S: That's all.
Monal S: Is this part clear now?
Monal S: Alright. Using the same concept, again, disabling the chat, using the same concept, now see, I'm giving you task, this is my new
Monal S: register V2.
Monal S: New register V2. It was already created? So let me create register V3.
Monal S: Alright? This is Register V3, more advanced version, where we have name and first name. Now, let's break it down one by one.
Monal S: I will copy and paste, then we will later write the code. One by one, guys, one by one. Very simple, you will understand. I want all of you to focus so that you will not lose something.
Monal S: I want to access our target.
Monal S: I want to access… This is our target, alright? Or better, let's access the date of birth.
Monal S: This is our target which we want to go.
Monal S: We have seen that, first of all.
Monal S: this target which we are saying, what is the main parent key? All of this value is a part of…
Monal S: First, we need to go inside the value. This value is present inside which key? 101.
Monal S: So first, we need to access 101. Let's write, there are two ways register… of 101.
Monal S: Another way is… register.get, because it's a part of dictionary, yes? Register.get, we will pass 101.
Monal S: It will give us what? It will give us what? Let's write it.
Monal S: Now, when we access it, it will give us the actual value of it. What is the value?
Monal S: This is the value.
Monal S: Alright? This is the value. Now, this value data type is what?
Monal S: This value which we are getting, the answer of these two codes, either you can use this or use this, is of what type now, what type you're able to see? It's a dictionary.
Monal S: It's a dictionary? Yes. So, dictionary will have its key, And its value.
Monal S: its key and its value. It's key and its value. So, we have 3 key value pairs. Which key we are interested in?
Monal S: which Kia we are interested in? We are interested in date of birth. So what we can do? We can use
Monal S: Register 101, Which gives us… we can use register 101, which gives us access to this dictionary.
Monal S: So this will be replaced by that dictionary answer. Now, if this is a dictionary, we can again use the index. So here, I will write date of birth.
Monal S: Similarly, this was the whole dictionary. To access the key, we use register.theKey. Now, we already have the answer. Inside that answer, this will be replaced by a dictionary. Dictionary, and to access the key, I will use this. This will give us what?
Monal S: This will give us what?
Monal S: This will give us this value.
Monal S: Which we have here.
Monal S: we have here. So let me show you in the code, then we'll check your questions. So first, let's focus on register V3 of 101.
Monal S: Yes, we are now inside the value of 101. If we wanted to target 102, we can use 102.103. Currently, it does not have any value.
Monal S: Done. Now, this is giving me dictionary. In this dictionary, what I want? DOB. DOB is a number or a string, it's a string. So I will write in a single code or double code, both are fine.
Monal S: DOV.
Monal S: None.
Monal S: So this thing will give us access to this value.
Monal S: So, this will be replaced by the value inside. Now, if I just write the type.
Monal S: and paste the direction to get that value, we will… Python will replace this with this value, and it will check the type.
Monal S: Tuple!
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: Yes, if you want to store this value from it, and let's get GET101 date of birth.
Monal S: Paste this. Now, you can use this value wherever you want.
Monal S: That's how you move inside things. If I want to target monol, then… guys, now I'm giving you assignment in the chat itself.
Monal S: This I have written for date of birth. If I want to target monol, now what should I do here? But before that, before giving the assignment, I want all of you to say whether you understood this or not. Start. Disabled. Chat enabled, sorry.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand how things flow?
Monal S: Yes, guys, this thing, you need to understand it by practice.
Monal S: Under… see, if you're a little bit confused, after a class, make sure that you do revision. I cannot teach you each and every comp… I'm teaching each and every component, but I cannot give you each and every structures of it, right? Walk through each and every, because it will take forever, okay?
Monal S: So, this is one of the methods, but at least are you able to understand that what we have to do
Monal S: What we have to do? Guys, you can go to N number of levels. You can go to n number of levels.
Monal S: Similarly, if you want to replace this with the GET method.
Monal S: What you will do, instead of bracket, you will use GET.
Monal S: GET will give you what?
Monal S: Guys, GET will give you what? What is the answer of this GET?
Monal S: It is a dictionary.
Monal S: If this is a dictionary, then can I use again.get on top of it, because Python will replace this with this.
Monal S: Python will replace this with this.
Monal S: get will be, accessible with this one, yes?
Monal S: Abhinav?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: We'll help you, raise your question at the end, okay? Raise your hands.
Monal S: So, when I do get off DOB, It will work.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Done. Guys, I'm just asking you how to traverse it. This is called as traversal.
Monal S: We want to traverse through the data that we want, and this is the direction. Using GET, this is the direction using list method.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: So guys, why we are writing it twice? Either you can use get-get, either you can use dictionary way, or you can use combination of dictionary and list. Python don't care what you are writing. You're a developer. Python will care that once I get this value, this will become dictionary.
Monal S: Is this, operation, is this code.
Monal S: Valid with the dictionary? Yes, it is.
Monal S: It gets replaced again and again.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Guys, class will get tough, don't worry, but this part, you only need to practice. You cannot become a developer. It's not… guys, development is not just always about A is equals to 2, A plus 1, this is not development. We are learning the foundation.
Monal S: We need to practice these things, we will get comfortable. Right now, I can see all of this structure in my mind automatically, without even looking at whether some things are accessible or not. Because I am doing practice. What you guys have to do, everyone who is able to understand, who is not able to understand, what is your task.
Monal S: What is your task?
Monal S: If not… able to… Understand.
Monal S: First step.
Monal S: Revise, record… watch, recording.
Monal S: Because the same thing I've taught, you know, we might need to listen 2-3 times. Once it is done.
Monal S: Practice.
Monal S: Okay? Create your own problem statement, what you want to store, then start storing it.
Monal S: If… You are… Able to understand.
Monal S: Ben?
Monal S: like this.
Monal S: That's why I don't give assignments when I feel like we are not ready for assignments. Is this part clear?
Monal S: Guys, you will not be able to copy code from chat, it is disabled. Is this part clear?
Monal S: I will show you one thing.
Monal S: Okay, I will show you one thing, just wait.
Monal S: Where is that?
Monal S: Best practice is the main key, okay?
Monal S: Just checking if something is maybe labeled here.
Monal S: Just a second, okay?
Monal S: Great, Anodak, great.
Monal S: Got it.
Monal S: If I show you this, you all will be… Happy. Oh, God.
Monal S: There it is.
Monal S: Too big here, okay? I will show you once it is downloaded, okay? I will show you one JSON, which you will be scared by looking into it. But it's not about JSON, it's about understanding the main basic. How do we iterate over it? How do we traverse over it? It will take 15 seconds to download. Let's wait for 15 seconds, I will show you.
Monal S: See, this is what I'm downloading.
Monal S: Let's wait 4 seconds, 3 seconds… 2… 1… And then… done.
Monal S: Let me extract it, it will not take long.
Monal S: Yes, please extract it.
Monal S: It is 500MB, Done, done, okay, found it.
Monal S: Open with VS Code, yes.
Monal S: Now see this, everyone?
Monal S: Are you able to see a similar thing like dictionary on the screen?
Monal S: But you will be able to see that my system is hanging, yes?
Monal S: Because if I do format this, let's see…
Monal S: if I will be able to format this or not.
Monal S: For some reason.
Monal S: Good luck, great.
Monal S: Right-click, guys, I'm… first it is loading just failed.
Monal S: Browser will crash.
Monal S: My system got hanged.
Monal S: Because it is trying to load all of this data.
Monal S: Say this?
Monal S: I need to reopen it. Let's reopen again.
Monal S: Let me reopen the short version. Short version is fine.
Monal S: This is the short version. Now you can see format. Let's wait, it will format it.
Monal S: Are we able to see how many lines this particular dictionary kind of thing has? See this?
Monal S: I will show you on top that how the value looks like.
Monal S: Is everyone able to relate to these dictionaries?
Monal S: Info has some values, license has some dictionary again. Inside it, it has values.
Monal S: See this?
Monal S: This is what you are going to use in your future projects, when you're going… you can see all of this dictionary.
Monal S: Which one is simple? This one is simple, or one I'm showing you is simple?
Monal S: So, what you have to do, this… the main point of showing this is that there is a lot of real-world data waiting for you. All you do is, once you get more comfortable, understand you can only do few things by doing pen and paper.
Monal S: Okay? Take a notebook, write things, understand what is index 0, what is index 1, what is this value, work with Python, do all of those things, and understand why output is coming some way.
Monal S: And then, once you're comfortable with that, later, not now, after a few months, you will be able to understand, at least able to traverse through all of this data.
Monal S: Alright, so let me close it. Don't worry about it, it is pretty simple. Right now, all of… because all the information is present in a single file, it is looking a little overwhelming.
Monal S: Okay? Done. So, I hope everyone is clear with how to traverse with anything. Same goes, guys, this is not just about dictionary. Dictionary will use GET, LIST will use that square bracket, but tuple will use that square bracket as well, the same indexing is falling everywhere.
Monal S: Alright, same index is following everywhere.
Monal S: So now, let's move to the last dataset which we are going to learn today, okay? The last dataset, then we will jump to some awesome things. This is more about how to concept, we have to remember it, but the next part, after the final dataset is going to be very simple, okay?
Monal S: Yes, great. Thank you very much, Vanya.
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Next dataset, let's move to the next dataset, and the final one is called a set.
Monal S: There are more. And in future, we are going to create our own
Monal S: our data structure, whatever we like, our own data structure, okay? But for now, we are focusing on the one which is used to solve certain things. Set.
Monal S: Okay? Set is the unique collection. Again.
Monal S: Suresh, did I manipulate it, or I just accessed it?
Monal S: Suresh?
Monal S: Does manipulation means accessing it?
Monal S: Accessing and manipulation is different.
Monal S: Guys?
Monal S: Did I ever update the date of birth?
Monal S: Anywhere?
Monal S: Are we able to see any update on the date of birth?
Monal S: Date of birth update will happen when I do this.
Monal S: This is call update.
Monal S: register V3 is not defined because we have closed this file. Let me run everything.
Monal S: Ow?
Monal S: Is this working? Okay, register V3. Again, there is some error because… Oh.
Monal S: It says register V3.
Monal S: Okay, see this. When I do register v3.get of 101, date of birth, what actually is going on? Let's see…
Monal S: Okay, okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Monal S: Oh, see this?
Monal S: We didn't change anything in the tuple. We changed the whole value itself. We were getting tuple here, but we replaced it with 10. So, to access the value of tuple, I should have written like this.
Monal S: I cannot update… I can change tuple with something else. I cannot change the value of tuple. I will show you how. This gives you tuple, but to access value of tuple, I need to write this. Yes?
Monal S: This is where we're accessing the value of tuple, yes or no?
Monal S: If I write it like this.
Monal S: Now it is giving us that we cannot access it, yes or no?
Monal S: Yes? So, guys, similar thing. Serious, why it happens?
Monal S: It is… Simply because if I write A is equals to 2,
Monal S: In the next statement, in the next statement, if I write A is equal to 3, what will happen? I told you from the memory what will happen. Previously, 2 was stored, the reference was given to A. When I give A equals to 3,
Monal S: Python will write 3, then the new 3 location will be given, this link will be broken.
Monal S: Similarly, if A is having a tuple of 1, 2, 3, this is tuple.
Monal S: It will store into the memory.
Monal S: This will be 1, 2, 3.
Monal S: If I write A is equal to 10, what will happen?
Monal S: A will now hold the location of 10, this link will be broken.
Monal S: Here, are we changing the value of tuple, or are we assigning a new address to the variable?
Monal S: we are assigning a new address to the variable. If I would have written something like this, then it will not let me update. Same thing was going here. If I write something like this.
Monal S: Now, I am accessing the whole tuple.
Monal S: what I'm doing?
Monal S: instead, whatever this key stores, I'm updating with 10.
Monal S: Is this clear now?
Monal S: This is a key, guys. Date of birth is a key. This is a value.
Monal S: If I access the elements of date of birth, that is the zero, now we are inside tuple, then it will not work.
Monal S: So here, we are assigning a new memory location. Here, now we are inside a tuple, it will not help us change it.
Monal S: Also, we cannot access tuple elements using .get, just write it as known. See?
Monal S: This is tuple now.
Monal S: Let's access 0.
Monal S: It works.
Monal S: Guys… Again, I'm asking, are we changing the tuple?
Monal S: Are we changing any value in tuple?
Monal S: Is it maintaining the same thing we told, that tuple is immutable? Yes.
Monal S: it is telling that tuple is immutable. Everything is correct, whatever you're saying. We are not changing the value.
Monal S: Okay? Understand, guys, because we are piling up concepts, we forget the basics. Is this basics important in the first class? Is this helpful now to understand things?
Monal S: Yes, it is helpful.
Monal S: Great. Okay?
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: Yes, probably it can have. Alright, what was the next topic?
Monal S: Set. Let's go to the set.
Monal S: Disabling the chat, focus on the set.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: What did I told about set? Set is…
Monal S: Only tuple is immutable. Set… this is a very important interview question. Someone asked me in the interview as well, but some people ask this kind of thing to trick you, okay? Set is… set maintains…
Monal S: the unique values.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: set maintains unique values. Even if you try to add duplicates, it will not allow it.
Monal S: So what is the first step… first line?
Monal S: to handle…
Monal S: To handle uniqueness, PU set.
Monal S: Okay? To handle uniqueness, we use set.
Monal S: And also…
Monal S: removes… duplicates automatically.
Monal S: Removes, duplicates automatically.
Monal S: Third?
Monal S: It accepts… only unique, immutable items.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: And this one is unordered.
Monal S: So… Just…
Monal S: Let me erase this because this might confuse it. For now, we will only go with 1 and 2, okay? Uniqueness and remove duplicates. Then we will check what it works with, what it does not. So, we have seen that, let's suppose I have created a list.
Monal S: I have created a list for a person 1. P1,
Monal S: This is a dictionary, this is Person 1, and these are attributes of Person 1. Let's suppose there is some issue with our system that it keeps adding, that it allows user to add things into the list. What will happen in the list?
Monal S: What will happen in the list?
Monal S: it will have duplicate values. But what we want is, we don't want to have duplicate values.
Monal S: For person details, guys, do you think that Tuple is a good option?
Monal S: For person values, do you think tuple is a good option? Tell me.
Monal S: Is tuple a good option to handle person details?
Monal S: Whole person details.
Monal S: I'm disabling… enabling the chat. Tell me, is it a good option or not?
Monal S: Do you think
Monal S: Having person details is a good option? No. I will tell you why. Because person details… today we have, my name and date of birth, tomorrow we can have added phone number, we can have… we can add their address. But if I make person details itself as a tuple, then we can never change it.
Monal S: Yes, date of birth can be tuple, but the whole set cannot be a tuple. Set means I'm talking about values.
Monal S: Okay? So, we cannot use tuples there. So, to remove duplicates, we have found that we can use set. Yes? So, we'll be using those set. So, let's see those set.
Monal S: Let's see how set works like, and how to create set as well, okay?
Monal S: That is that value.
Monal S: set. Syntax of set might be…
Monal S: a little confusing, but keep this in mind that this is how Python works, okay?
Monal S: Sit.
Monal S: I'm creating values like, let's say, Guest.
Monal S: Okay? Set also starts with curly brackets, but set does not have key value pair. Keep this difference in mind. Set does not have key value pair, but set also has curly brackets. Whatever I write in this set is going to be same. Okay? Allies. Alice.
Monal S: Alice?
Monal S: Let's write tanmeh.
Monal S: Tanme… And let's write 123 Android, 101, 123, and let's write… So that's it.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Which values are duplicated?
Monal S: Alice?
Monal S: 123? That's all.
Monal S: If I run it, And if I print guests, See what it does?
Monal S: What it does.
Monal S: Tanme, only one time. Sudarshan, Only one time.
Monal S: Alice is only one time, 111123. It removed duplicates automatically.
Monal S: One more thing.
Monal S: Let's see the behavior.
Monal S: It is not… it is not ordering something. Order changed, that's why I've mentioned there, it is unordered.
Monal S: It does not maintain an order, it changes things based on some operation, but don't say that it is going to sort something in your set, alright? It is not sorting your set, it does change the order, you can see, previously it was A, now it is B.
Monal S: So, don't consider whatever the order it is giving. What we should be using it as, we should be using it as set of information. That's all. This is what we should be using set for. For a set of information. Just give me a second, guys.
Monal S: Alright. Okay? So just like a list, we should be using it like this. Are we clear?
Monal S: So what is the plus point which we have seen? Let me write… That it removes duplicates Also…
Monal S: We need to keep this in mind, know that it is unordered.
Monal S: Whatever order we will pass data, it will not maintain this, and it will sort it automatically, but not in alphabetical sort. It just does something.
Monal S: Alright? It is unordered.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So, some of you are asking that, how to create empty set. You can see that this is where we are starting. To create an empty set, you can use something like this. Let's suppose you want to start guest with this, okay? You can write set.
Monal S: When you mention function of set, it provides you an empty set.
Monal S: You can just print guest, and you can see this is set empty.
Monal S: Is this fine?
Monal S: Are we clear? Alright.
Monal S: How does Python know that we have defined set? Because we are using function.
Monal S: And then, it will return us… guys, we will understand later class and others. You can see this is class set, okay? So don't worry, but if you have to use it, you can use it something like this. It is totally acceptable. Or you can… we cannot use something like this. See, when I use guest is equals to this empty, what it will do?
Monal S: What it will do, think about it, what it will do.
Monal S: It will think it as a dictionary.
Monal S: Empty dictionaries created like this, but not set.
Monal S: Similarly, if you want to create tuple, this is where we were creating tuple, right? Let's start through the tuple part.
Monal S: If you want to create anti-tuple.
Monal S: empty tuple, just use this bracket. Let's print…
Monal S: a pipe.
Monal S: It is tuple. Or, you can also create empty tuple like this.
Monal S: And it will also give you the same thing. So there are multiple ways. Whatever you feel is less confusing, use that one.
Monal S: Alright? How to differentiate? Differentiate using the type.
Monal S: Okay? Differentiate using the type. And when you print tuple, when you print tuple, you can see it is giving us…
Monal S: Where is that?
Monal S: brackets.
Monal S: And here, it is giving you… Curly braces.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Yes, guys, you can create lists like this as well.
Monal S: But list is automatically very simple, list we can use like that, or we can create list using this.
Monal S: print… type of a… and type of B.
Monal S: Both are lists.
Monal S: Clear.
Monal S: Are we clear, everyone?
Monal S: Simple.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Okay, now that we are talking about list, you can see that alpha is a list, everyone? Okay. Guest is a list. Guest is a list. Now I will talk about how to add elements.
Monal S: to a set.
Monal S: Okay? How to add elements to a set. Guys, what did we use to check to add elements in a list?
Monal S: What we use to add elements in list?
Monal S: Append. Here, we use add. If I add 10, and print guest.
Monal S: I will print before and after, so we will see what was before, what was after adding it.
Monal S: What happened? Dictionary object has no attribute. Where is dictionary? Oh, did we create it like dictionary?
Monal S: No, we didn't. Oh, I think I changed it.
Monal S: See this? It's working now? Yes, because I defined it again. Is this part clear? See, I added 10, but tan got added in between.
Monal S: 10 got added in between.
Monal S: So, I'm giving you one very special function, which will help you sort few things, just like this alpha that we have, right? So, to sort things, you can use use function
Monal S: sorted.
Monal S: to sort… elements.
Monal S: This is alpha. If you wrap alpha with sorted.
Monal S: you will see ABDGZ. Is it sorted? Yes.
Monal S: If you print alpha, is alpha sorted? Yes.
Monal S: So, it sorts that value, okay? You can also use sorted… Let's suppose…
Monal S: Is it sorting? So, sorted is a function which helps you sort the values in ascending or mathematical order.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Are we clear? Now, similarly.
Monal S: If this is alpha, and alpha is already sorted, everyone, alpha is already sorted, so the values of alpha are changed now, yes? See this? Is alpha changed?
Monal S: Tell me, is alpha changed?
Monal S: Tell me Zulfa changed. No.
Monal S: Because sorted here, you need to store the value of sorted. This is sorting and giving you the value. You need to save it back. See this?
Monal S: You need to save it back.
Monal S: So, sorted alpha will give you new sorted list that you are going to save it back here.
Monal S: Now, if I print it, is this sorted?
Monal S: Is this sorted?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: So that's how you use it. Now that this is sorted, now if you print alpha, alpha value is changed. Now, it is not the value which we provided at the start. It has become a new memory space because the value is sorted. Now, see this new functionality of sorted.
Monal S: I am creating this new functionality of sorted. So here, I will write, in a new variable, alpha reverse.
Monal S: Here, it provides you new attribute or function I told you before, right? New tool to do it. Here, if you mention reverse is equals to true.
Monal S: And print reverse. This print this variable.
Monal S: See this?
Monal S: Now it is the reverse of the original alpha, this alpha which we created.
Monal S: So, when we do reverse equals to true.
Monal S: It does the sorting in reverse.
Monal S: Is alpha here in the list? Guys, yes. You can see, this alpha that we created, this alpha. You can see this alpha that we created here first, but what we did, we created it to a list.
Monal S: So, we change something. Not that, wait. This is sorted? Yes. Sorted gives you answer in… guys, sorted is giving answer in list, okay? Sorted does not provide the answer in, set.
Monal S: If you want to see set, let's see… That's tweet.
Monal S: Let me bring the alpha here, so I will show you.
Monal S: Guys, coding is fun. Guys, don't get confused. I'm not adding new functions, that's why I was keeping this sorted for next class, but for now.
Monal S: That's it. What is the type of alpha?
Monal S: set. Now it is set. Okay?
Monal S: Now what it has become? It has become a list.
Monal S: Alright? So you can see…
Monal S: Guys, read the description of Sorted. What it does, in the first line, see this?
Monal S: Read the first line of this function. This is the information of this function. What it does…
Monal S: It returns a new list containing all the items from the iterable in ascending order.
Monal S: By default, ascending. If you want to make it descending, we will use reverse. Is everyone clear now with the working?
Monal S: Is everyone clear now with the working?
Monal S: And this completes our data structures advanced one. I know, it was a lot of detail, but I want all of you to cover
Monal S: All this in very depth.
Monal S: Yes? Everyone happy with today's class?
Monal S: Hi, everyone.
Monal S: S?
Monal S: After sorting a set, why does it become? Because, Alfred, that function is written like that. Later, once you learn more programming, you can create your own function.
Monal S: To make it a set.
Monal S: Okay? Make it as a set. And if you don't like it, guys, what we should do, if you don't like the answer in… if you don't like the answer in…
Monal S: and list.
Monal S: Can we do this?
Monal S: Typecast?
Monal S: The final answer will be set again.
Monal S: Yes, guys, I understand.
Monal S: Is the final answer will be again set.
Monal S: This will give you sorted list. Sorted list will then be converted back to set.
Monal S: And then, it will be saved to alpha.
Monal S: You can do whatever you want. Once you understand typecasting and other things, it is pretty simple.
Monal S: So, again, recap. I'm again just doing the recap of what we have done today, okay? You guys will help me.
Monal S: No, it will… it will be unordered if we convert it, but if you want it set, then it will be like that, yes. Set, by default, tells you that it is unordered. The main function of set is duplicates.
Monal S: See, in programming, in an interview, they will give you a question.
Monal S: In my list, I have… I have multiple things in duplicate.
Monal S: Either you will use the DSA algorithms.
Monal S: To remove the duplicates, or you can use… or you can use…
Monal S: Tell me, or you can use, just…
Monal S: Convert this whole thing to set, and the duplicates will be removed.
Monal S: done, because this data structure's already allowed it. That's DSA tutorial, not right now, but later. Okay, let's recap whatever we have done. I know we have done a lot of things. List.
Monal S: List.
Monal S: Square brackets, list has… append.
Monal S: List has… Bob?
Monal S: List has… remove.
Monal S: List has… insert.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Later, we have more things in the list, but you guys can talk about it later, okay? Set.
Monal S: Can we create set like this?
Monal S: Can we create set like this? By set. Can we create set like this? No.
Monal S: Set needs to be created with set.
Monal S: Set has… Ed.
Monal S: Okay? Set has add. Set also has update function, but I will tell you later, whenever we are going to use it, okay? We can add a few things using update, and it will update it. But for now, we are going to use it, okay? So, guys.
Monal S: pop and remove. One works with index, one works with value. What we have seen, dictionary.
Monal S: Dictionary has how many?
Monal S: Guys, a dictionary list also has index, yes. Index is a part of Python itself, not just a data type, anything that is iterable index value, index present here.
Monal S: It is key value, And .get… And we have seen… dot get.
Monal S: Index, as well as default value.
Monal S: If we don't find it.
Monal S: Guess?
Monal S: Tuple.
Monal S: Do we have any append or something here?
Monal S: Perfect.
Monal S: Do we have any here? No.
Monal S: Typo in set.
Monal S: Creation?
Monal S: Therefore, guys.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: And sorted is something which we can use to iterables, okay? We can use to mutable iterables. So, sorted can be used with list, can be used with set.
Monal S: Final answer it provides is… Output as providers is in list.
Monal S: We have also seen length function.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: We have also seen
Monal S: Yes, Ravi, there are a lot of things, okay?
Monal S: Right? So, length. Length can be used with…
Monal S: String. Length can be used with iterables.
Monal S: How many of you are… Very tired today.
Monal S: Very tired. How many of you can learn few more things?
Monal S: I might not be able to complete all, because we are already learning time, but we have learned these things in very depth, yes?
Monal S: Very depth.
Monal S: So, tomorrow's class is already a little short, but what I will do… do you want me to shift it, or just give some introduction? Enough for today, very depth. Great.
Monal S: Yes, guys, I think you also need time, because it's already 12.18, and it's time for discussion, push and discussion, alright? Doubt discussion. But I think you have a lot of things to start. Guys, while loop I can cover, but
Monal S: It will again take 10-15 minutes.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Kaizai will address everyone's, okay? Don't worry.
Monal S: So, let's shift everything, and don't worry, tomorrow's class, I want everyone to come with more energy. It will not be this extent, this,
Monal S: extensive like today's class, but it will be a little simpler. So we will be able to complete everything, alright? So let's complete everything tomorrow. So here, let me even erase it from here, because we don't need it.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: So, guys, thank you very much for whoever has joined this class. Let me stop sharing for a second.
Monal S: And, I hope everyone liked today's session. I'm raising a poll.
Monal S: Again, I know some people will have an issue, but guys, whoever is having issue, if you write negatively, I will not be able to help you, but if you write in a way that you guys are expecting, which I can also do, I can also help you.
Monal S: then I will listen to that feedback and improve. Always. Okay? But if a target is not for improvement, but just for complaint, then there is no possibility of improving. What I will do with improving?
Monal S: I hope everyone understands.
Monal S: I am here to help you, you should also help me understand what you guys really want.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Thank you very much, guys. Guys, assignment today is revise all the things and do permutation combination, what works, what does not, because right now we are not ready for assignments of this. Once we're ready, tomorrow I will give you assignments.
Monal S: Sir, what's your secret to staying calm when people throw basic stuff? Guys, I feel like I'm a little less calm than the previous batches, but I feel like,
Monal S: this batch has more advanced people as well, advanced in terms of experience, alright? So, some people are getting confused because they were using different technologies or in a different field, so they need little time to
Monal S: erase whatever understanding of Python and everything that they have. Then only they will be able to focus in Python.
Monal S: But my patience is… this is my superpower, and this is what I'm learning, okay?
Monal S: Guys, Wednesday… Everyone knows what is about Wednesday class.
Monal S: Everyone knows And guys, please also redirect everyone who has questions regarding it. I have created a,
Monal S: a different link for there, right? Whatever questions that they have.
Monal S: Can we get lecture-wise timeline? Monday, I will try, but that is not really possible, but I will try. I will… I will… I'm going to add that into FAQ.
Monal S: Alright, only people who has doubt, and I will suggest everyone, whoever is raising hand, guys, if you think your doubt can be something which you can solve by permutation and combination, then please do it, alright? That is the best way to learn. If you have doubt which cannot be solved by you even after trying, then ask me.
Monal S: Is this fine? So whoever has raised his hand, think about it, then unraise. That will be best, me as your mentor.
Monal S: Because after this batch, what I will be going to gain from you? The only thing I can gain from you is if you have good remarks for me, right? So, bye guys, whoever has joined today's class, bye-bye, see you tomorrow. Guys, VS Code theme, I'm using Cyberpunk. Check which one of the Cyberpunk which you like.
Monal S: Difference between set and dictionary, Bhamsi?
Monal S: Dictionary uses key value, set does not uses key value, okay?
Monal S: Alright. Amit from Netherlands. Hey, Amit.
Monal S: Amit, are we there?
Monal S: Dinesh. Dinesh, you're next.
Monal S: Amita, are you there?
Amit - Netherlands: Hello? Can you hear me?
Monal S: Hey, Amit, yes. Amit is first. Yes, Amit.
Monal S: Yeah, yeah, sorry, I did not raise my hand. Everything is clear to me. Sure, sure, that's fine. Thank you so much for your session, I think I'll… Thanks, Amit. Yeah, thank you.
Monal S: Alright, then we have Dinesh. Dinesh, you're next.
Monal S: Thank you very much, guys, thank you.
Monal S: Cheers are, I will do that.
Monal S: Guys, no coupons, okay?
Monal S: For coupons, people are already explained that. We do have limited coupons, so it is a little hard for us
Monal S: And we have to get with you. Check with Udemy, get with the coupons. Right now, it is expired. All the people have already utilized it. But in future, if you get it, you guys will for sure get it again.
Monal S: Alright? But for now, this class is also enough in your basic level. Once you feel like you want to learn more things, then we can discuss around it, okay?
Monal S: Can it be used as typecasting? I don't know, I taught you typecasting, but,
Monal S: If, after revision, you're not able to understand, then I will teach you again, okay? HP, you are next.
Monal S: HP?
hp: I don't…
Monal S: Hey, hey, SP. Yes.
hp: Yeah, I'm audible, madam.
Monal S: You're audible, HP, yes.
hp: Yeah, my question is, regarding… I was trying to store list.sort function in a variable, but it was throwing error.
Monal S: Pist.sort.
hp: list.sort function.
Monal S: Alright.
hp: For example.
Monal S: Yes.
hp: For example, list, One very…
Monal S: list, you don't save list.faud in a variable. It, you don't need to save it again. It saves in the same variable automatically.
Monal S: Are you clear?
Monal S: If you try to save it again, it gives you none.
hp: Can I share my screen?
Monal S: I will share my screen.
Monal S: See, this function I didn't taught you, but still, if you want to do it, see this. This is what you're doing.
hp: Okay, I don't…
Monal S: Right?
hp: Yes.
Monal S: What you're doing?
Monal S: If you save it again, back to…
Monal S: If you save it again back to A, What will happen?
Monal S: I told you.
Monal S: It will be none. You are not supposed to save it back to A, it automatically does it.
Monal S: Is it working?
hp: Okay.
Monal S: Anything else?
hp: What's the reason behind, like, why it's showing none?
Monal S: It is showing none, because it… when you learn some function, it does not return anything, it… do you know about functions and classes?
hp: Functions, I know, yeah.
Monal S: it does not return anything. If something does not return anything and you write it like that, if it is returning none, what will happen?
Monal S: Are you clear?
Monal S: If the function returns the sorted list, then only it will make sense, but right now, it is not returning anything.
Monal S: Okay, that's why it is giving us none. Are you clear?
hp: Yeah, sure. Thank you.
Monal S: Yes, you're welcome. Alright, so…
Monal S: Next, HP, if possible, undrace your hand once you're done, okay? Yeah, Abhinav, you're next.
Monal S: Thank you very much, Mohamed.
Monal S: Yes, thank you very much, Mahal, for trying. Yes? Yes, Abhinav?
Abhinav singh: Hello, Monolsar, how are you?
Monal S: I'm doing good, Abhinav, how are you?
Abhinav singh: Sir, my doubt is regarding to, sir,
Abhinav singh: variable register V3. Sir, can you please share your screen? I will share my screen. Sure. Thank you, sir.
Monal S: register…
Abhinav singh: V3.
Monal S: 3. Let me search through it, okay?
Monal S: register V3.
Abhinav singh: Vitty.
hp: Yes.
Monal S: Yes.
Abhinav singh: That… studying this, 101 key-value pair, so I'm not able to…
Monal S: This is value.
Abhinav singh: Gee, sir, gee, sir. Thank you. Sir, in this, key-value pair, I'm not be able to find where is, this tuple is stored.
Abhinav singh: So that I can access through this indexing.
Monal S: But, are you able to see tuple?
Abhinav singh: Yes, sir.
Monal S: So what do you want to do here?
Abhinav singh: Sir, I want to do that, just like you, indexed how to access this, data…
Monal S: Okay, first of all, are you able to see Tapal here?
hp: Oh, goodness.
Abhinav singh: Yes, sir.
hp: How's it.
Monal S: Tuple is present inside.
Abhinav singh: Apple is a value of…
Monal S: Pete. Yes?
Abhinav singh: Yes, sir.
Monal S: This key and value is a part of this dictionary.
Abhinav singh: Yes.
Monal S: To access this value, first of all, tell me what you will do.
Monal S: To access the value of 101, how you are going to write?
Abhinav singh: Register?
Abhinav singh: Yes, I've written a register.
Monal S: Then?
Abhinav singh: 101?
Monal S: What it will give you? It will give you access to this.
Abhinav singh: Thank you, sir.
Abhinav singh: Thank you.
Monal S: Now, are you able to understand?
Abhinav singh: Yes. Then later…
Monal S: Then, this will be replaced, Python will replace this with… This whole thing.
Abhinav singh: Okay. Yes?
Monal S: Now, if this is a dictionary, and you want to access date of birth, this whole thing will be replaced with dictionary, just like you written 101, right?
Monal S: To access this dictionary, you access the key.
Monal S: Now, if this is the dictionary, and you want to access date of birth, what you will do?
Abhinav singh: I will create one more.
Monal S: This is this dictionary, see this.
Monal S: Does it… sir, does it applicable on, each data type?
Monal S: Which data file? Which one?
Abhinav singh: that this, DOB…
Monal S: See, if you re… can you please reframe your question? What exactly you are saying? It's totally fine, don't worry, yeah.
Abhinav singh: Okay, okay, sir. My, question is exactly that, sir.
Abhinav singh: If data, DOB is stored in some other data type, maybe I can access it.
Monal S: DOB is a data type, this is key, but of data type, string.
Abhinav singh: Okay, sir.
Abhinav singh: Okay, sir, my last doubt is regarding to, alpha variable, in which you have,
Abhinav singh: Explain short, shorter.
Monal S: Sure.
Monal S: So let's see, Alpha… yes.
Abhinav singh: Yes, sir.
Monal S: Okay, so, are you able to understand that this is a set?
Abhinav singh: Okay, sir.
Monal S: It is a B…
Abhinav singh: Hmm.
Monal S: Yes, this is A because this is set because it does not have key value. Dictionary and set uses the same curly bracket, but if you mention key value pair, then it becomes dictionary. But if you don't write key value pair, this will be set.
Abhinav singh: Okay, sir.
Abhinav singh: Sir, on what ba- sir, on what basis this A, B, D, Z, G was sorted in this list?
Monal S: Alphabetical.
Monal S: Okay.
Abhinav singh: alphabetical or alphabetical concept in programming.
Abhinav singh: Sir, there is a concept in programming SK values. Does it follow…
Monal S: ASCII values are also ASCII values.
Monal S: ASCII values are already sorted, okay? Even if you check the ASCII values, ABCD are sorted or not in ASCII values.
Abhinav singh: Yes, sir.
Monal S: ABCD is sorted, yes. So, it uses internally those concepts of it, and then sorts it, but it is not just ASCII. Here, you need to write the logic of, because it's a method. You can see sorted. Sorted, when it sees some value, it will internally use ASCII, but range of ASCII. ABCD will be sorted differently than 1234, yes?
Monal S: Here, if you see, I have added A, B, C, D, G. If I add one.
Monal S: and sort it. You can see that it is giving us error.
Monal S: Because we cannot decide that 1 is greater than G is greater than Z.
Monal S: Are you clear? Because we are trying, this is a string with number. So, it will work either with number, or work either with…
Monal S: string.
Abhinav singh: I think.
Monal S: Okay?
Abhinav singh: Okay, sir. Thank you very much, sir.
Monal S: variable, yeah? Sure, sure, no problem.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: That is done. Then we have Sumit. Sumit, you're next.
Sumit Das: Thank you, Munay, sir. It was a great session.
Monal S: notes? Yeah, sure, sure, Sumit. Yes, thank you.
Sumit Das: I have one question regarding the coupons, sir. So, I think Krish, sir, mentioned that in the first induction that, he'll be sharing in the next weekend class, coupons for the Gen AI and generative AI and machine learning Udemy courses.
Monal S: Yes, yes, Christian mentioned that he will be sharing it once it is available. Because of the generative and other things, when we get access from the Udemy, then only we share it. But before that, we got access to NA10 and other things, right?
Monal S: Okay, yeah. Yes, so that's how we got the access, yeah.
Monal S: wanted to go through the language and those things, that's why I… See, that is… see, that is some offering which we try to give. It is not a part of the main syllabus, right?
Monal S: So, he tries to that whenever Christ has some offering, Chrysler do that. So, Christo told that we will be giving an offering, but I don't think so that he's accessed… he has given access to that from the Udemy right now.
Sumit Das: We will be able to check things,
Sumit Das: If it is possible, would you be able to check if that can be obtained?
Monal S: Krisha directly tells us. We don't even have to tell, alright? So, I will check with team, but usually, that is not under control, even with us, okay? We directly… if we get it, Krisha directly shares with it, yes?
Sumit Das: Sure, sure, thank you.
Monal S: Yeah, yeah, thanks, Amit.
Monal S: Alright, Muhammad, you're next.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: So…
Monal S: Hello, Monster, how are you? Yes, yes, I'm doing good, how are you?
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Yeah, I'm good, good, thank you. Such a hot day here in Australia.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: So, just, I have one doubt, like, the concepts which you are teaching me, it's, like, really, to be honest, it's, like, really helping me a lot. But, the thing is, like,
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: like, suppose take an example of, like, you have taught us about the data structures, this week. So I tried solving the, this… I tried applying these concepts in hacker rank, questions.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: So, whenever I tried solving the, like.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: this in, like, it's supposed to take an example of list, so I just search in HackerRank list, and if I tried solving the questions, like, I'm unable to solve the questions in HackerRank, like, I, like, exactly, like, I'm not getting the logic, like, how to apply, like, I'm.
Monal S: I know, I know.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: but mainly.
Monal S: Mahmat, next week, I will tell you, okay? Next month, in Feb.
Monal S: I already have this thing playing, I'm going to create my, first or second YouTube video on that, where I will be showing 30 questions, okay, in a single video. This is applicable for all, because I know this particular batch, or even someone who wants to understand the logic building.
Monal S: How to think in terms of logic has to start from somewhere. And if you directly start from hacker rank or something, it will… you will feel demoted and not even able to do the same, right?
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Yeah, yeah, I'm…
Monal S: So right now, right now, forget about that, wait for, in, in Fab, 1000%, I will be creating one video. You will get… you might, you might get more than 30, different questions, and once you complete that particular playlist or a single video, I've not decided whether it is going to be multiple videos.
Monal S: Then, you will feel comfortable that what… I'm able to do the logic, now I'm ready to start with HackerRank, okay? I'm not going to teach DSA, but I'm going to teach you logic.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Yeah, I was about to ask these questions, like, to solve the Accurant question, like, do I need to… do I need to have a prerequisite of DSC data structure?
Monal S: Oh, no, no, that is different. See, DSA will come there, but there are other things which require some logic, okay?
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Okay. Project, yes.
Monal S: So, similarly, okay, Ravi and Sohel, guys, everyone raised… hands is raised, okay? They are on the queue.
Monal S: And, yes, Mahmat, sorry about that. So, if I talk about,
Monal S: Me, personally, I have ignored my reasoning questions that comes when we prepare for companies, right? Reasoning in terms of, if a train is moving with a speed of X, if a train is moving, then how fast the station is going to come, something like that, right? Yeah. All have seen certain kind of questions. So we kind of, ignore that caution.
Monal S: But now that I've become senior, I felt that that was the purpose
Monal S: should never be to solve questions. The purpose should be
Monal S: how quickly our mind should click to solve something. What is the main logic behind it? So, logic actually comes before coding. Coding is where we solve things, but logic is something that how to solve it. That is what we will do.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Oh, okay, I got it.
Monal S: We'll talk about it, don't worry, okay? I will create.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Okay, I'll.
Monal S: From the video, which will help everyone.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: So, as of now, I'll just follow, like, whatever you're.
Monal S: Follow this course, but that 50, 30 questions, 40… whatever I'm going to plan is going to really, really help everyone for interviews.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Oh, yeah, yeah, sure. Thank you so much, like, and also I have one last question. Like, even Chris, like, mentioned about the DSA data protection algorithms, Udemy coupon code, like, is it…
Monal S: We are trying, okay? DSA was planned, I think DSA, VG were getting it, but right now we didn't get it. But if you get it, for sure, because Mangsa created that course on DSA, right? If you check on the.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Monal S: Man Sarat actually planning to come, but for some reason, I'm not sure I will check with him, that DSA is not provided, or if he didn't get any access on that.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Yeah, sure, thank you.
Monal S: That was really plain, okay? Sure.
MOHAMMED ABDUL KAIF ALI: Thank you. Thank you so much, have a great day for you. You too, you too. See you.
Monal S: Alright, guys, I am able to access everyone's chat, I'm able to see everyone's chat.
Monal S: Jaya Vendra, I'm able to see your chat.
Monal S: Sohel, Ravi, everyone's able to see your chat, but see, guys, I have to follow queue, I cannot be biased, and then whoever is doing the chatting will be first, right?
Monal S: So… I will do one by one, okay?
Monal S: Just wait a second, don't worry. Break and continue. Guys, this is the final thing. After thought, we will close the session.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Hello?
Monal S: Hey, hey, Monmouth, yes.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: a couple of things, just to revise. The difference, between set and,
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: The additional.
Monal S: study. Yes.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Yeah, if, if, there is no key value, like, key value is null, then… .
Monal S: If it is not key value, it is not a dictionary. Dictionary main foundation is, it should have key value.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, okay, there are, for example,
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: four key values, and one key value is missing, that can be stored or not.
Monal S: will be error. No error.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: That will be okay.
Monal S: There is no… yes, yes.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: And then, the sorted, two things about sorted, you told. That, sorted does not change, the order.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: in the variable? In the variable set. But.
Monal S: Yes.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: It changes order in the, it changes the variable in the list, you said.
Monal S: the variable.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Dot list, if you're using the list, then the, order is changed and saved to the variable, list.
Monal S: The set, first of all, it does not even maintain an order. So even if we convert from list to again set, we should not expect list… set to have an order. Okay? We convert from X to Y, Y to X, set should not… set does not guarantee that it will have an order.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, but in case of list, if we use sort, then.
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: List will maintain order, because we use the function to sort, set, and then the final answer it is getting in a list. So list is sorted.
Monal S: Abigail.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, and we use dot, for sorted, in the set, we use…
Monal S: started, I used function C. Someone asked that question, I think that's why you were getting that confusion.
Monal S: Where is Zoom?
Monal S: Sort, I told you function, I didn't told you sort method. Method, we use dot. You can see this function?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Yes, yes. This is a function, okay.
Monal S: Yes, this is the function, okay? Dot, whenever we had dot, it is method. That method I didn't taught you, that was someone else query.
Monal S: Okay, okay. Vamshi, can you please wait, Vamshi?
Monal S: S…
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Thank you, Mona, it was a very good session. Thank you.
Monal S: Thank you very much, Mohammad. Thank you.
Monal S: Okay, this is Vamsi's doubt, Vamsi. Register V3, if I want to access first name with, the same date of birth, register.get.name.
Monal S: you got the name, and if name is the dictionary, then you can get the first name. This part is done. So this one, you are printing the first name, and here you are printing date of birth. This is working, but printregister103.getFirstName.
Monal S: Vamsi?
Monal S: Vamsi, guys, can you tell me in the chat why Vamsi is getting error?
Monal S: Ramsi, how can first… first name has date of birth? Do you have dictionary inside first name which has date of birth, Ramsci?
Monal S: Date of birth is a part of person's 101 attribute, not the first name, not the date of birth.
Monal S: Vamshi, you are, you should see this, where you are using date of birth is not in the same level. Date of birth is in the level of 101.
Monal S: It's a hierarchy issue, I'm sure.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: And guys, resource, you will get, after a few minutes, okay?
Monal S: In the meantime, I'm zipping everything… yes, harsh Jen? Hirsch, you're next.
HarshJain: Hi, Maul, how are you?
Monal S: Hey, Harsh, I'm doing good, yes.
HarshJain: Yeah. Hey, Munal, I have one question. So, so for this, set, we… when we declare an empty set, we use parentheses, right? And same, we use for tuple.
HarshJain: So, we have to define set, before the parentheses, and same for tuples. That is what, right?
Monal S: two methods. Two methods. You can use any of them.
HarshJain: No, no, if we, for example, if we declare as empty set, just like, S equals to, just, set, we have to mention the set there, right?
HarshJain: If it is giggling, we are giggling, say, empty set.
Monal S: Empty set, yes. In set, you need to mention set.
HarshJain: So, enter, same for tuple as well, right?
Monal S: And tuple, you can just mention, without… there are two methods in tuple. Either to create tuple like this.
Monal S: or write tuple.
HarshJain: Okay, okay. In tuple, we can create without missing tuple info.
Monal S: In set, we cannot do it without that function, because set also uses curly braces, and curly braces, by default, is a.
HarshJain: Perfect.
Monal S: vaccinate again.
HarshJain: Dictionary, yeah, okay, got it.
Monal S: Okay.
HarshJain: Thank you so much, it was a great session.
Monal S: Thank you very much, thank you.
Monal S: Alright, and… Jayanth Krishna.
Monal S: Hey, Protiva.
Jayanth Krishna: Hi. Hi, Munel.
Monal S: Audible Gent? Yes, you're an audible gen, yes.
Jayanth Krishna: So, yeah, so my question was, like, I, I was not able to, attend earlier classes because I was, out of station. So I was going through the recordings, and in one of the, in one of the recordings, maybe it's 14th of January.
Jayanth Krishna: Like, it was shared about the…
Jayanth Krishna: That, course, Udemy course, this one, coupon code.
Monal S: this issue, okay, Jen? Everyone, I think a lot of people will have it. So, Jenth, I'm speaking to everyone who's having this issue, okay?
Monal S: So, guys, Udemy course coupon is given, and Udemy course coupon is limited, okay? We don't have access, to create new ones. If Udemy gives us that access to provide, again, free for that.
Monal S: then only we can get it. So, from our side, we want to give you free courses, but Udemy only provides constraint, alright? And that constraint has been fulfilled, so we cannot create more. If you're able to create more, then we will again provide it, but for now, we don't have it.
Monal S: Okay. So this happens to all the courses, even mine, because, guys, here you are a lot of people, not just one, not just two. We have a lot of people. So, if a lot of people clicks on it, there is a limitation, and that gets fulfilled.
Monal S: So that's why, Giant, we want to help, but here, we don't have control over it. Yes.
Jayanth Krishna: Okay, okay. And also, the second question is that, so, like, I'm going through the earlier recordings, but I'm not sure if there were any assignments that were given in the earlier classes, and how…
Jayanth Krishna: And are they… and what is the, like, let us say if we want to submit the assignment, what is that procedure?
Monal S: Jenth, see, in my class, what I do, because here, if I check assignments of each and every people, it might take me 2 weeks just for a single assignment, just to check it, okay? Because here, we have a lot of people. So, assignment, whenever I give assignment, I give for this… for you to practice, you to understand that how exactly question is.
Monal S: What is the ask, whether we are able to solve it or not.
Monal S: So what you have to do, if you think that your assignment is, not correct, or you're not able to understand, we have a community. Jayanth, have you,
Monal S: Tried our community chat.
Jayanth Krishna: Right, right, yeah, I see.
Monal S: So, paste in the community, or ask the same… paste the same question, because now we have LLM. LLM is kind of our own mentor now, right?
Jayanth Krishna: So, in LLM?
Monal S: provide the question along with your solution and check whether it will work or not. If it is working, it's fine. If it is not, then try to change that, alright? So, assignments are usually provided for you to practice and be familiar with problem shit, that's all.
Monal S: It does not require any marks or something, because you're not in college, right? So, yeah, yeah. So that was my main goal, that's all. There is no other agenda behind it.
Jayanth Krishna: Okay, yeah. Yeah, thanks, Manil, it was a very quick session.
Monal S: Thank you, thank you, and thanks for joining this badge. Yes.
Monal S: Alright, just give me a second.
Monal S: Let me upload 24th folder, 24th…
Monal S: Just give me a second, okay, everyone? I will be back.
Monal S: That is it.
Monal S: Guys, everyone will be able to talk, don't worry.
Monal S: Just need a few more seconds.
Monal S: This is… 24012026…
Monal S: What did we learn today, guys? Let me check, because I need to write the same thing.
Monal S: Thus… Owen.
Monal S: primitive data types.
Monal S: And if you provided any dis… anything, no? So, let me share so that everyone has access to…
Monal S: Last knobs.
Monal S: Which will also be available in the original section, as I mentioned.
Monal S: Alright, so guys, I have updated the class resources in the Notion, which… the link I have shared, so you guys can share the same. I will also attach the same in…
Monal S: However… Messages, data science, And you will have there as well.
Monal S: 24… Zip. Guys, Zip is available,
Monal S: In the community, Zip is available on the resource section, central resource section, which I mentioned, along with what we have done today. And that's all, okay?
Monal S: All right.
Monal S: So, where were we?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Hi, Bami?
Monal S: Hello, how are you?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yeah, hello?
Monal S: Yes.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yeah, I'm fine. Thank you so much.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yeah, thank you for the wonderful classes, right? I've been… I've been following for… I mean, since we started the class, and trust me, the class has been amazing so far. I mean, you made it so, so easy.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Thank you. Right, thank you so much for that, yeah.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: So, my challenge is basically for the class to be sincere. Your explanations are very, very, very clear to be sincere, but my challenge is, is that I've not been able to implement, right? I've been having issues with the VS Code.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: I've downloaded it times without number, to be sincere, but I was unable to open a folder. For example, I would create a folder.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: And by the time I want to open, it's not really opening, and I've tried all my best to be sincere.
Monal S: Can we… can I promote it to a panelist, and you can share your screen?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Alright, yes, yes, I can share my screen.
Monal S: Yes, yes.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Thank you.
Monal S: You're welcome.
Monal S: Guys, thank you very much for joining, and whoever is dropping out, we'll see you tomorrow, alright?
Monal S: Thank you, guys.
Monal S: Alright, yes.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Oh, sure.
Monal S: You can see green button there, in the.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yes, yes, I can see.
Monal S: Yep.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: I'm gonna share my screen.
Monal S: Alright, your screen is loading.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Can you see my screen?
Monal S: Yes, I can see your screen. Alright, so let's start by creating folder.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Okay, I'm coming.
Monal S: D.
Monal S: You do use IDM. I was using IDM, like, 5, 6 years ago.
Monal S: Yep.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yes, this is mine.
Monal S: Alright, let's click on File, Open Folder…
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Okay, open folder.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Whatever folder you want to open, let's open that.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yeah, new photo, right?
Monal S: Yes, yes, let's create a new folder, wherever you want to work, okay?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Okay, okay.
Monal S: Let's create writator Data Science 2.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Data science.
Monal S: Yeah, write data science, yep. Is this fine? Yeah, yeah. Is this fine? And then click on select folder.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Okay, select for that.
Monal S: Just click on that.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: I guess, no.
Monal S: Wait, let's see…
Monal S: Can you, because in this folder, you don't have anything, right?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Can you click on Outline?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yeah, right?
Monal S: No, this is not the right way, let me see.
Monal S: Because… Timeline.
Monal S: Two files here.
Monal S: Yes, guys, we'll see you tomorrow.
Monal S: And, can you minimize open editors and outline?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: What'd he say?
Monal S: When you minimize open editors and outline, there is that downward-facing arrow, right?
Monal S: Left to the outline, there… left to the outline. You can see.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Look at you.
Monal S: Yeah, this is one downward arrow, yes, click on that.
Monal S: Let's close.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Right.
Monal S: Similar do for open editors.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Okay.
Monal S: Okay, I think we are able to see, but because you don't have any file, can you open terminal? Let's see if a terminal is in the correct place.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: a year?
Monal S: Yes, you click on Terminal.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: I agree.
Monal S: New terminal, yes.
Monal S: Click on New Terminal.
Monal S: See, you are inside data science, alright?
Monal S: Can you click on that three dots on the Explorer? Yes, Lizzie, thank you very much. Let's see. Yes, can you click on that? Yeah, click on that.
Monal S: Here, yes, everything is open. So… Okay.
Monal S: Folders is missing for Q, right?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: And I… I did follow all the steps you showed.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Doing the installation.
Monal S: of what version of Windows you're using?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: I don't know, how do I check it?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Windows…
Monal S: I can see another folder icon for you. Can you click on the last folder icon? On the very left, you have extensions and other things, right? Can you click on the folder icon below the extension? Can you see extension? Four boxes.
Monal S: Like, Windows icon on the very left side.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Cover your mouse a bit.
Monal S: Yeah, there is extension, a little bit below, little bit below. Similar to that, there is another explorer. Can you click on that?
Monal S: Click on… a little bit below, a little bit… yeah, this one. Can you click on that? Here you have folders, can you…
Monal S: Yeah, this is your folders.
Monal S: Your VS Code is a little weird. Yeah, your VS Code is a little weird for some reason, but this is your folders, okay?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Thank you.
Monal S: You can create new file folders, just like we were showing. If you now do in CMD, if you open CMD and do, UVVENV, it will create it here.
Monal S: Okay?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yeah.
Monal S: Are you clear now?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Thank you, so how do I… how do I do that?
Monal S: Yeah.
Monal S: Now, this is a little weird, because for some reason, your VS Code has two of these file icons. I've never seen it. But yeah, whatever works, works, right?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yeah, how do I do it? How do I create? I can create a folder here, right?
Monal S: Yes, you can create folder, and using the terminal command prompt, you can create your virtual environments and follow those sessions to do the environment setup and other things, okay?
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Alright, thank you.
Monal S: Yeah, sure, you're welcome.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: Yeah, finally, thank you.
Monal S: Yes, yes, now you will make progress. Thank you.
Monal S: Yeah, thank you.
Ayobami Iyanuoluwa Awosanya: M.
Monal S: Alright, Suhail, you're next.
Monal S: Guys, in every system, this is called as debugging, okay?
Monal S: Yeah, hi Mul.
suhail bashir: Yep.
Monal S: So, I have…
suhail bashir: three, queries. One query is… it is general query, and two among them is, technical query.
suhail bashir: So, the first queries, regarding the NSU Ready AI projects with deployment that Chris has, launched recently.
suhail bashir: So, at this point, as you know, that our foundation is not that strong in AI.
Monal S: Yep, yep, yep.
suhail bashir: What would you suggest?
suhail bashir: Should we enroll at this point of time.
Monal S: whole product, no, no, no, don't enroll. That whole product, it was mentioned by Krisha that don't even join that if you don't have the prerequisite, okay? And the prerequisite for that whole product is, you should know things in order to build things. That is about building it.
Monal S: Right? So, for now, I will not suggest it, but once you know… once you complete it through machine learning, then I will suggest to jump there and create projects.
Monal S: Because they are available to remote Docker and other things which might overwhelm you.
suhail bashir: So, to this… to that level, I mean, how many months it will take for us to…
Monal S: Take for 5 to 6 months.
suhail bashir: Six months. Okay, great.
Monal S: Sure.
suhail bashir: Yeah, the second technical query is, with respect to, sets.
suhail bashir: As they are, immutable, right? So if you're having…
Monal S: Tuple is immutable.
suhail bashir: I'm talking about set.
Monal S: Yeah, set is not immutable.
Monal S: Seth, you're able to add value.
suhail bashir: Right, right, right, right. So, if you're having a list of, tuples inside set.
suhail bashir: So, we can have it, right?
Monal S: See, that… let me see this. This is what you're saying, right?
Monal S: If this is a set… And then you want to add list of tuples.
suhail bashir: Right.
Monal S: Right?
suhail bashir: As tuple is immutable, so we can edit, right?
Monal S: See if we can add it, it is added.
suhail bashir: Okay. Yes? My question is now, suppose, as list is mutable, and if you're having a list of tuples.
suhail bashir: Or some immutable objects.
Monal S: See, you cannot add… see, set itself is mutable, but the value inside is immutable. So, if you want to access A of 0, which is what? See, set object, not this one, you cannot access set like that.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Instead.
Monal S: We should be using some kind of a method. Yeah, it is iterable, okay?
Monal S: To use it, let me… there's… indexing does not allow Zinset.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So you can only iterate over it. So, iterate over means for I in A, then you can iterate over it. Now, when you're iterating, you cannot change the value.
suhail bashir: No, no, no, my question is… my question is, if set contains a list of immutable objects, for example, tuple, right?
suhail bashir: And now consider a scenario where list is having objects of immutable.
suhail bashir: Object, suppose tuple. A list of tuples.
Monal S: Let's stop tuples, yes, okay?
suhail bashir: Why can't it be an ideal candidate for set to have?
suhail bashir: Immutable list.
Monal S: Set also has immutable, right?
suhail bashir: No, no, no, I'm saying… you're not getting my question, actually. Yes, yes, yes. So, I'm saying, I'm saying, I'm saying, let us have a set, and that set is having a list of…
suhail bashir: tuples.
suhail bashir: Okay.
Monal S: of tuples.
suhail bashir: Right.
Monal S: Yes?
suhail bashir: Okay? And now consider I'm having a list of, list of, Set a list of tuples.
suhail bashir: So that is doable, right? Inside list, we're having tuples.
Monal S: Sweet.
Monal S: Inside list, we have tuples. This is tuple. Right?
suhail bashir: This is ridiculous.
Monal S: Why this is not doable.
suhail bashir: But now, if I put this list inside set.
Monal S: Got it. Can you see this error?
suhail bashir: And yeah, that is what I'm saying.
Monal S: This is unusual. Now I will tell you. Yes, now I will tell you, okay?
Monal S: See, this is the way set is made, okay? Now, if I talk about the concept, let's go back to the dictionary.
Monal S: Okay? In dictionary, if you check, here, if you apply string, what is acceptable here? String?
suhail bashir: numbers.
Monal S: Numbers, as well as tuples.
suhail bashir: It's tuple, right? Right?
Monal S: So, a string is hashable, numbers is hashable, tuples is hashable. These all are, these all are, by default, immutable.
Monal S: Are you clear?
suhail bashir: Yeah.
Monal S: If something is immutable, it means you can create a hash for that. If something is by default mutable, it means
Monal S: These are,
Monal S: This can be changed at any point in time. If something can be changed, this hash will also change, so hash will not become reliable.
Monal S: Yes?
suhail bashir: Okay.
Monal S: So if hash will not become reliable, then we cannot use it as a key or something in the dictionary. That breaks the main foundation of the dictionary itself. Similarly, set.
Monal S: Alright? Set, what it does? It removes duplicates.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: It removes duplicates, it also uses hash value to remove duplicates.
suhail bashir: Yes.
Monal S: If two values will have the same hash, it means we can remove one.
suhail bashir: Right.
Monal S: Oop?
Monal S: If I add lists inside a set, which is not immutable.
Monal S: Will I be able to even check hashes of tolists?
suhail bashir: But my question was, like, if list contains immutable, objects, but by default is the nature…
Monal S: Yes, list can contain immutable, but something that allows no… something that allows only mutable objects, that is a set, you cannot have inside that. So, inside this, you can create it, but list… but set itself does not allow any list to be present inside it.
Monal S: Even if… yeah, even if it contains immutable objects, right? Yes, yes, yes.
suhail bashir: Okay. Okay, and the last one is, like, sorted. You showed a sorted method, right?
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes.
suhail bashir: If you're having heterogeneous elements in that, I think the sorting doesn't work there.
Monal S: Yeah, it doesn't work, yep.
suhail bashir: Okay.
Monal S: it uses that operation that bought something if something is bigger than something. I cannot say string A is bigger than 1.
suhail bashir: So…
Monal S: Right?
suhail bashir: It should be a similar kind of, yeah, sure, okay.
Monal S: Yes.
suhail bashir: Thank you, thank you so much.
Monal S: Yes, sure, you're welcome.
Monal S: Alright, then this is done.
Monal S: Then we have Ravi. Ravi Albani?
Ravi Lalwani: Yeah, hi Monl.
Monal S: Hello, yes.
Ravi Lalwani: Yeah, so two queries, basically, I don't have any technical query, as I'm a technical person, so… nothing on the technical side. But, I wanted to have, I mean,
Ravi Lalwani: clarification on the Wednesday classes, they were to be… supposed to be the Dowd classes, or, like, it is…
Monal S: No, no, no. Wednesday is kind of a booster classes to speed up our course, that's all.
Ravi Lalwani: In Wednesday, we don't even take syllabus, don't even take doubt.
Monal S: Okay.
Ravi Lalwani: Because those are the working days.
Monal S: Those are short classes, yeah.
Ravi Lalwani: I understood, but what I'm trying to say, Wednesdays are the working days, it's a hectic schedule for many out there, right? So that is the reason I… Yeah, so whatever doubt sessions we are having today and tomorrow, like, if we could do those on Wednesdays, that would have been a great thing, rather than…
Monal S: but we will not be able to boost up our classes. See, this batch, we have already tried once. Batch 1.2 is there, okay?
Monal S: we tried running on you on Saturday and Sunday, but what happens is that, because the first initial phase which I'm going to teach, that is the basic and foundational part of everything, right?
Monal S: It gets a little slow because people have doubts. I teach it a little slow so that everyone can be able to consume it. But after 6 months, we can speed up things, right? So, what we're trying to do, we are trying to reduce that 6 months to a little bit less. So…
Monal S: we were able to complete things faster, so it will not extend more than one year. That's the main goal here, Ravit. Okay.
Ravi Lalwani: Okay, understood, but it is little… not little, but it is active.
Monal S: It is hectic, I totally understand.
Ravi Lalwani: Yeah, I don't, I don't… I'm not complaining anything on the technical background. I know, I know, I know, I know, I know, I know. I understand. The second part to this is, like, why don't you have the separate batches? Because people are there who are not technical, I mean, they are not having the technical background, right?
Ravi Lalwani: rather than having everybody in the single batch, why can't you communicate, I mean, commutate, people into different batches and have…
Ravi Lalwani: different batches, so that, whatever I was trying to say, and, you were saying that things would get speed up after 6 months, that would have been.
Monal S: No, everybody is speed up.
Ravi Lalwani: Yeah.
Monal S: Yes. Yeah. See, I will tell you, okay? When I was teaching computer vision batch here, there was one live computer vision batch, okay?
Monal S: I have seen technical people, 5 years, 15 years, 20 years. Non-tech people, 15 years, 20 years as well, right? I did some, understanding that even tech people, you cannot compare tech people with tech people again. There can be groups who will not understand, there can be groups who will understand.
Monal S: So you will never have a clear separation with non-tech and tech first.
Monal S: There will be a lot of people from non-tech who will be able to surpass people from the tech people also.
Ravi Lalwani: That is very rarest chance, but at the nitty-gritties are there.
Monal S: Good for you.
Ravi Lalwani: Northern.
Monal S: It's not rare.
Ravi Lalwani: No, nitty-gritty, I mean, whatever you're talking… so, I… today, when I was attending, this is just a simple discussion I'm seeing, right?
Monal S: Yes, yes, I know, I know.
Ravi Lalwani: This is not to offend anybody, yeah, I am not… this is not to offend anybody. On the call itself, if anybody's feeling bad from my word, I'm sorry. But the only point is, like, you were talking about tuples, and then, set, and then lists, the questions were. Now, when we want to print A,
Ravi Lalwani: it is printing a value, and when you want to print, say, a list is A, it is printing its whole value. People are not able to understand that, because they don't have the technical background. That's not…
Ravi Lalwani: Their problem, but that's not…
Ravi Lalwani: What do you say a technical person would not be knowing, even if it is, like, very less in the experience?
Ravi Lalwani: These things would matter, a lot in the longer run when I say, when I talk about this, right?
Ravi Lalwani: So, I'm not blaming anybody. It is totally… it is totally fine if they are coming from different background. The only thing, the group has to be homogeneous rather than the heterogeneous, to get things aligned.
Monal S: You are true there, okay? See, I will tell you that in Christian Academy, if you see, we don't have any mentors that are not capable of teaching things. I'm not talking about capability.
Ravi Lalwani: No, no, no, I'm not…
Monal S: No, no, no, no.
Ravi Lalwani: I'm not doubting anybody's capability over there.
Monal S: No, no, it's not about doubt. What I'm saying that we have one mentor for Agentic, one for data science, one for CV, one for NLP, and other things. It's not about capability, it's about… Correct. We are not bringing anyone to do something which we cannot tell to someone that, no, we are providing certain level of quality to these people, alright?
Monal S: So, what we do, this Ultimate Data Science in the prerequisite itself, we try to mention that we will cover everything from the very basic if you don't know. So, in the initial phases, it will sound a little slow.
Monal S: But after 1 or 2 months, these people will also have the same knowledge. I will not say that people coming from BTEC also are good in coding, no, they are not. They understand all the theory. You can agree on that, right?
Ravi Lalwani: Yeah, yeah.
Monal S: So, this initial phases of one or two months, you might feel that, okay, there should be a separate group, but once we pass that group, everyone will be on the same. So, it is like, for two months, if everyone on the heterogeneous or not, they will be able to understand everything, just for… in the initial phases, for 2 months, we will be able to understand it.
Monal S: We will be able to bring everyone on the same page. So it is.
Ravi Lalwani: I'll be more than happy if I can help on that part as well. I can also take some basic classes.
Monal S: All right. Thank you. Yes. Thank you, David. Thanks, thank you. Yeah, I totally understand what you're saying, but yeah, when we think in terms of scale, this kind of becomes…
Monal S: more easier in terms of scale, but our progress is right. Only one back…
Ravi Lalwani: Yeah.
Monal S: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yes.
Ravi Lalwani: No, at least, at least, there should be some bifurcation. If they are BTECH, or at least… not BTEC, I'm just saying, if they are having a technical background, they would align much, easier, and the non-tech people would… Now, whatever you're teaching is, like,
Ravi Lalwani: I used to learn that in 2010, right? Yeah, so that's what I'm saying. So in 2010, I have all learned all this. So, that's the reason I sometimes get, what do you say, least interested in the things. Maybe because.
Monal S: This could be my… I know, I know.
Ravi Lalwani: Yeah.
Monal S: See, that's why what we kind of suggest always is that for people who want to do FastTech on a certain part of the course, right, we already have Python, we already have some kind of things, so if you want to do fast tech quickly on Python, just wait on Python. In the meantime, if you're already familiar with coding, because trust me, ultimate data science is not the final goal.
Monal S: This kind of course will bring you to a stage where you can, figure things out by your own.
Monal S: Generative AI, agentic AI, anywhere. But you will not be an agentic AI master, yes? So, in the meantime, if you are someone who are good in technical, maybe fast-track the courses which are already… fast-track on things which are already provided.
Monal S: And instead of, instead of doing things on the slow pace here, learn things parallel as well, because there are hundreds of things which we need to learn.
Ravi Lalwani: I, I do that, I do that.
Monal S: Yes, yes, that is good, that is good, right?
Ravi Lalwani: I do that. Yeah, but I don't want to get into that mode where I don't want to, attend this class, I just want to get into the, what do you say,
Ravi Lalwani: have myself, disciplined into this, attending these classes, because going down the line after 6 months, everybody, or whatever you will be teaching, or in this class, would be newer to me as well.
Monal S: Yes, yes, that's what I'm talking about.
Ravi Lalwani: Yeah, so…
Monal S: So, this bridge itself, I totally understand, but this bridge itself is going to close soon. So, you will not feel this way, right?
Ravi Lalwani: Fine, no problem. Thank you.
Monal S: Sure, Avi, thanks for understanding.
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: All right, Shiva, you're next.
Monal S: Eva? Okay. Bahram?
Monal S: Baldram, are you there?
Balaram Bala: Actually, I was asking about the theme part, Manulsar.
Monal S: If you had everything.
Balaram Bala: So, I was able to apply cyberpunk theme, but the background color is not coming…
Monal S: there are… in Cyberpunk, there are still 3-4 more, right?
Balaram Bala: Okay, if you want, I can share my screen.
Monal S: Yes, yes. See, this is just theme. Don't worry about theme, but yeah, share your screen. Guys, whoever wants to get the same thing… see, personally, I just use this theme because
Monal S: Maybe 2 months after, I will use a different theme. Just wanted to get something new. Just like my phone, right?
Monal S: So, if you want to do that, do that. But in the meantime, Chandan?
Balaram Bala: Okay, here…
Monal S: Yes, okay, see, this is one of the cyberpunk. Can you click on set color theme?
Monal S: Now, you only get one, because you installed Cyberpunk 2020, can you re… can you go to the second Cyberpunk? Second one? This is what I installed. Install this one.
Monal S: This will… see, it is giving you 4 options.
Monal S: Good?
Balaram Bala: It looks…
Monal S: like me, it looks like mine, right? Select any four which you like. Mine is kind of purple. Can you select on… let's see… this one is also good.
Balaram Bala: This one?
Monal S: Right?
Monal S: See, select any one. I'm not exactly sure which one is mine, but I think I've used red one, I've used…
Balaram Bala: Yours is, like, a little PowerShell kind of theme, that's why I…
Monal S: See, I need to check which one I am using.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Sure, how to check, just wait.
Monal S: Thank you.
Monal S: Deck. Ctrl-Shift plus P…
Monal S: Control button is not working.
Monal S: Restrate, okay?
Monal S: Can you ride jellyfish?
Monal S: No, go to extension, go to extension and search Jellyfish.
Monal S: Daddyfish.
Monal S: Right, jellyfish.
Monal S: Which, and there is something called a… Yes, click on that.
Monal S: Install.
Monal S: Yes, trusted.
Monal S: Yeah, click on Jellyfish.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: I am using this.
Balaram Bala: Yeah, thanks.
Monal S: Yeah, alright.
Balaram Bala: Thank you.
Monal S: Yeah, sure, you're welcome.
Monal S: Alright, no, it was Balram.
Monal S: Alright, Shiva, are you done?
Monal S: Chandan, you're next. Chandan?
Chandan Kumar: Hello.
Monal S: Something has happened to Shiva. Yes, hey Chandan, yes.
Chandan Kumar: Hey, hi, hi Motosaur, yeah. Good afternoon, sir, and it's a really good class, because I've been a non-tech, non-tech guy.
Chandan Kumar: So, I'm understanding a bit in…
Monal S: That's great. See, soon you will not even call yourself tech or non-tech. You will just call yourself as, soon-to-be data scientist, soon to be an engineer, yep?
Chandan Kumar: Yes, yes, yes. Because I'm there in HR field, so people are getting worse, get stuck in the basic knowledge the developer do get.
Chandan Kumar: In the interview question there, the interviewer do ask the basic questions first, to eliminate the lot of.
Monal S: Yes, yes, they will do that, they will do that.
Chandan Kumar: So, sir, actually, I have some, question. Could you please, can I share my screen?
Monal S: Yes, you can share your screen.
Chandan Kumar: Hello.
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes.
Chandan Kumar: Yeah, sorry, sir. Actually, the screen, I'm facing some difficulty for skate screening.
Monal S: So, I've just pasted one query on this.
Chandan Kumar: board.
Chandan Kumar: On chat section. This helps push it once again.
Chandan Kumar: Yeah, so this is the QD.
Chandan Kumar: So, if, I put, like this, it came, it come as name only. So, I've, I've, resolved this one, that I have to put, yeah, to…
Chandan Kumar: I have to resolve it for,
Chandan Kumar: like, I have to put, once again.get, and then I have to put the name, then I'll get the name as Chandar.
Monal S: See, let me share my screen.
Monal S: And see what you have done.
Monal S: See this? This is what you are doing.
Monal S: Why there is a comma?
Monal S: The comma showed.
Chandan Kumar: No, no, I'm getting only name, if I'm doing this.
Chandan Kumar: As, in the output.
Monal S: See first. What do you want to check? Date of birth.
Chandan Kumar: Yes, yes.
Monal S: If you want to check date of birth, then remove name.
Chandan Kumar: And if I have to check both, then I have to put, get once again, then…
Monal S: Now, if you have to do both, both you cannot get. You can only get one at a time.
Monal S: Then, you can write different for name.
Monal S: Whatever you want. This will give it a different value, this will give a different value, no two at a time.
Monal S: At a time, only one.
Chandan Kumar: Okay.
Monal S: Okay.
Chandan Kumar: And, one more thing. Actually, during the assignment that, have been provided, I was doing… I was able to do 4 questions without using help of any ChatGTP or any, like.
Monal S: Yeah, that's great.
Chandan Kumar: So, I'm just able to do only 4 questions only. I'm glad I'm stuck… I was stuck in that, pizza topping questions. That bullion was there.
Chandan Kumar: Yeah.
Monal S: This is a segment.
Monal S: See, I will help you. Where is pizza topping? This is pizza topping.
Chandan Kumar: that for.
Monal S: Okay, let's read through this, then others, you will try, okay?
Monal S: So, this is Pizza Topping Calculator. A customer is choosing toppings, each toppings… see, each toppings add a specific cost regardless of the other toppings chosen.
Monal S: Input 3 Boolean, it means these are the inputs. You will first ask user, do you want extra cheese? User can say, yes or no, true or false. Is this part clear?
Monal S: This is the first input. Second input is, do you want pepperoni? True or false? Third is, do you want olives? True or false? Okay? So this is three inputs which we need to take for cheese, pepperoni, and olives. Is this part clear?
Chandan Kumar: Yes, yes.
Monal S: Next.
Monal S: Here, we are saying that even before taking input, we will initialize the total bill to 0. So, even before user adds cheese, pepperoni, or olives, we will create a variable with a total bill of 10.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: I will see this for you, okay? See this. What we have done? First, we will do this. Is this what you have written? Scenario.
Chandan Kumar: Yes.
Monal S: capacitor. Next.
Monal S: If extra cheese, if pepperoni, if olives. So here, what we are able to see, there are 3 if. So, what we will do, if…
Monal S: Then what it is, if extra cheese is true, then add 2. So what we will do, say this.
Monal S: We will take 3 inputs.
Monal S: Input.
Monal S: Extra cheese.
Monal S: Alright? We will say user either provides 0 or 1.
Monal S: 0 for yes.
Monal S: Zero for no?
Monal S: 1 for… yes. Is this clear? Just giving an more instruction to user. And then what we will do?
Monal S: Is this clear as well?
Chandan Kumar: Yes, yes.
Monal S: Alright, so hear what you're saying.
Monal S: Extra? Jeez.
Monal S: As this completes, that we need to take one input. Similarly, what we will do, we will check for…
Monal S: Pepperoni.
Chandan Kumar: Oops.
Monal S: I'm just writing in short.
Monal S: Extra pep. And next was… Policy.
Monal S: So, first we initiated the build to 10, then we are asking user to take input. So, once we have all the inputs, is this part here?
Chandan Kumar: Yes, yes.
Monal S: So, now all the input is done. Our processing is required. So, what you will do?
Monal S: If extra cheese, what is the condition I've written? If extra cheese is true, then add 2 to bill. So, it will run, if it is false, it will not run, right?
Chandan Kumar: So what do you.
Monal S: I mentioned, if extra sees, then what you will do?
Monal S: Added to.
Monal S: Then, if pepperoni, because we want this condition to work separately, right? We want all of them to run.
Monal S: If extra pepperoni, then how much value we need to add?
Chandan Kumar: 3.
Monal S: For olives, we need to add one to the bin.
Monal S: 3?
Monal S: And one. Once it is done, what we need to do?
Monal S: Print the final bill.
Monal S: Print total bill.
Monal S: So, let's run it. First of all, I will say, okay, one thing we have missed is…
Monal S: Just wait that this is Boolean. First, it needs to be converted to integer.
Monal S: 01 will be string, it will be converted to integer, yes?
Chandan Kumar: Yes, yes.
Monal S: Then integer 01 will be transferred to Bull.
Monal S: Clear? Not at all.
Chandan Kumar: Correct.
Monal S: Do you want cheese?
Monal S: Tell me, they want cheese?
Chandan Kumar: Yes, yes.
Monal S: You want cheese. Do you want pepperoni?
Chandan Kumar: Yes. Alright, do you want olives?
Chandan Kumar: No, no.
Monal S: You don't want all this. 16. 10 was the initial bill.
Monal S: 10 plus 2 is 12, 12 plus 3 is 16. You didn't want olives, so it is not 17.
Monal S: Are they clear?
Monal S: This is assignment.
Chandan Kumar: Actually, I was… I was doing this extra cheese, and I was thinking that, can I add… I was putting that operation add in that input only. So, that's why I was not… Right.
Monal S: Let's do this.
Chandan Kumar: what's.
Monal S: It's fine, it's totally fine, see. Okay, first read it.
Monal S: And see the initialized build part, and it's done. So guys, yes,
Monal S: 10… alright, yes, we are getting one issue, because it should be 15.
Monal S: Correct suggestion, Arun. I see, previously, I've written extra cheese. It should be extra only, right? Extra cheese?
Chandan Kumar: Yeah. Extra watches.
Monal S: Right? Three conditions. Thank you, guys. So now, I want…
Monal S: No olives. 15. Now it is correct. 10 plus 5.
Chandan Kumar: Okay.
Monal S: Ben?
Monal S: Alright? So read, read a few things. I know it's hard at the start, but that's what I'm given. So read it, and see what it does. Secondly, read it, let's try to check what you can do, and then done. Else, ask in the community, don't try to,
Monal S: check multiple things and keep on trying, because the more you try, if you're not able to solve, then the more frustrated you will become. If you're not able to do it 2-3 times, maybe ask someone in the community that, what exactly we need to do with, or my solution works or not. Or maybe ask their solution.
Monal S: Okay?
Chandan Kumar: Yes.
Monal S: Pretty clear.
Chandan Kumar: Could you please paste that seed? Yes, yes, sure.
Monal S: I will share this to everyone.
Monal S: Okay.
Chandan Kumar: Thank you, thank you.
Monal S: You're welcome, you're welcome.
Monal S: Alright, ratamesh?
S B Prathamesh. G: Hi, I'm Monal. Yeah, so, first of all, thank you for the.
Monal S: Thank you.
S B Prathamesh. G: informative sessions that you have been taking, and I look forward for the entire course. I have, like, 4 topics to be clarified. First one is related to the dictionaries, so if we are having multiple dictionaries, how can we get the DOB value from those multiple dictionaries in one go?
S B Prathamesh. G: Because whatever I have seen today, it was like we are retrieving a single, key value, right?
S B Prathamesh. G: So, if we are having multiple dictionaries, how can we get at a single dictionary? Yeah.
Monal S: See, right now, I have not told you how to iterate over all of those, right? I will tell you, but it is not a part of today's class, so I will just show you solution. Explanation, I will provide later. Is that fine?
S B Prathamesh. G: Okay.
Monal S: Okay? This is register V3.
Monal S: This is what you're saying?
Monal S: Let's make it as 102.
Monal S: First name, let's make it as Rajesh, because Rajesh is the last name I've seen, and date of birth, let's say, 11. Is that fine?
S B Prathamesh. G: Yeah.
Monal S: Alright? So, register V3, let me print it at the bottom.
Monal S: Because I'm going to delete it. I will delete this as well. Okay, I will keep it. This is register V3, right?
Monal S: Here, why we are able to see this? Because I think I've not ran that register V3.
Monal S: values, so let me update it.
Monal S: Done. Now, we will be able to see it.
Monal S: register V3. 101, 102. Yes?
Monal S: Now see the logic. For I…
Monal S: So…
Monal S: Don't be scared, okay?
Monal S: Alright, so this one we are able to get.
Monal S: So, what we want, we want B of… Yay.
Monal S: Yes?
S B Prathamesh. G: Okay, yeah. So we are declaring K and V in this fourth statement, right?
Monal S: Yeah, K and D.
Monal S: Key?
Monal S: And value.
S B Prathamesh. G: value.
Monal S: this for loop and other things, we'll talk about later. It might confuse other people, okay?
S B Prathamesh. G: Okay, okay. Yeah, yeah, these are just different variations of conditional statements. Okay, the second doubt I had was, like, it would be better if you could give examples of real-world use cases of all these.
Monal S: See, I want to understand, because, see, it's totally fine, but what exactly do we mean by a real firm? Then only I will be able to help.
S B Prathamesh. G: Like, somewhere down the line, we are going to learn about machine learning. So, in machine learning, how these terms are going to be used.
Monal S: to use that.
S B Prathamesh. G: Yeah, if you give a brief now, then later you will be able to connect the dots, like, okay, in the previous session, we had learned something, and we were told.
Monal S: Yeah, I will tell you. These are called as foundations. If I talk about alphabets of English character, English language, those are ABC. Does it have any meaning? No.
Monal S: Then we make something from A, then it becomes a bigger picture. Right now, I can tell you, once we jump into the go to the functions and classes, then the problem statement will become bigger, right?
Monal S: I would talk about machine learning. Machine learning in the field of software development is a very small thing.
Monal S: Machine learning provides you functionality. The main software that we create has logic like this. If I talk about WhatsApp, WhatsApp is catered for machine learning, or it is catered for us.
Monal S: Now, WhatsApp as an application is catered for us, or for machine learning? No, not for machine learning, right? Machine learning, when you pass input, it just gives you output.
Monal S: Now, that output, how you're going to interpret for users. So, whatever we are learning, the if and else, if we are relating to the real world, this real world, not from machine learning. If we're able to relate with the real world, then we can create applications for users who are in the real world. So, in machine learning, let's suppose weather, right?
Monal S: Machine learning task is going to predict whether what is that degree, what is that degree Celsius, but what you want at the end?
Monal S: you have… today's… tomorrow's forecast is this degree, Celsius. What is that? It is real world.
Monal S: Yes. Do you get your point? So, whatever we are learning, this foundation itself is going to… whatever we are understanding, we should relate not to machine learning, we should relate to
Monal S: every day's use cases. Then only it is better for us to understand that this is how we should read it in real world. What is programming? Programming is converting all the logic, everything is about real world. Programming is converting all this logic, so we make sense of how to communicate in coding.
Monal S: Once you are good in that, it is totally doable.
Monal S: But if I talk everything in terms of derivation and others, then… see, if I talk about derivations, okay?
Monal S: Derivations that we have learned, we never got related to, what it… what we should do with that, right?
S B Prathamesh. G: So that's why we were never able to understand derivations truly.
Monal S: But in programming, it is opposite. First, we should understand how to use and solve daily use cases.
Monal S: Because if you check DSA also, DSA travel problem, we write DSA for find the nearest ATM. That algorithm is made for that.
Monal S: Google Maps. Find the nearest hotel to us.
Monal S: There is an algorithm to find that path, okay?
S B Prathamesh. G: So…
Monal S: So, most of the things are to solve the real world, then machine learning, and when you come… machine learning, you will not even write EFLO.
Monal S: In machine learning, you don't even use if statement, if-else. That is, after machine learning has done prediction, we will create if-else statement.
S B Prathamesh. G: Oh, okay.
Monal S: Okay.
S B Prathamesh. G: Okay, and the third topic was related to this VS Code block. So, as you have shown, we are creating different blocks to have the different output, right? Yes. Why can't we use a single block? Because when we…
Monal S: single block, but it… see, currently what we are doing, we are in experimentation phase. If I want to see output here, I have output here. If I want to see output of something else, I can have. I can also write things here.
Monal S: This time, I have to print it. You understand the working of this one, right? Why I need to print it?
S B Prathamesh. G: Yes, but the thing is, we are having.
Monal S: Everything is cluttered.
S B Prathamesh. G: Okay…
Monal S: Everything is cluttered. I have to read this whole thing, but previously, it was more easier for me to understand.
S B Prathamesh. G: Right? But when we go into the production code, we don't use notebooks.
Monal S: At that time, what we will do?
S B Prathamesh. G: We will not even do print statement.
Monal S: There, we will write the actual logic. We don't even have print statement in the production code, okay? We will just see the logic, and then that logic will do something that will help some other process. In production, we don't use print statement, okay?
Monal S: Okay, so the screen statements, they are executing, and we are able to see the output, right? Yes.
S B Prathamesh. G: But some of the, executions, I saw only the last code line is getting executed, and the previous.
Monal S: Yes, that is the functionality of this IPYMB. But in script file, you always need to print if you want to see something.
Monal S: Okay.
S B Prathamesh. G: Okay.
S B Prathamesh. G: Okay, so I just wanted to give my background, like, I have 15 years of experience in IT industry, and currently, since 5 years, I'm working in the automotive software,
S B Prathamesh. G: domain, and already a part of voice assistant for automotives, and whatever examples you gave about weather and navigation, they are a part of my day-to-day work, so…
Monal S: Awesome, awesome.
S B Prathamesh. G: Yeah, yeah, I can relate to those words.
Monal S: So you also see, right? In automotive, that is, like, a part of the vehicle and something, but automotive, at the end, is kind of catering to us, right? So, if a car… if you're not able to relate to car dashboard, that your button should be there, you should stare left and right, the high-level things.
Monal S: We should start from high level, then slowly move to the low-level things of how things are working.
Monal S: Then we will use the strangest if and else condition there.
S B Prathamesh. G: Okay. I've also seen some other, experienced people over here who are asking, like, for another batch, which is starting from February.
Monal S: That is Generative AI, course. That is a different course.
S B Prathamesh. G: But we are covering those things in our current courses.
Monal S: We are covering those things in current course, but those will be… see, everything has a detail to it, alright? Suppose here, we are covering machine learning level 10. We are covering Generative AI Level 5.
Monal S: But that course will expect that you know the machine learning, and they will… they might cover to levels 7 and 8 of Generative AI, because that is more towards that Generative AI part of it.
Monal S: There are a lot of things with Geneti web, but here, you will have a foundation that once this course is completed, now you can jump to any specialization that you want.
S B Prathamesh. G: You can go there, yeah. I will check with your team if I will be able to, like, parallelly
S B Prathamesh. G: Join both of these courses if there is no overlap or conflict of time.
Monal S: Yeah, yeah, sure, sure. Yes, you can check with them.
S B Prathamesh. G: get benefit of this. Yes, yes. Thank you, Modak.
Monal S: Yeah, thanks for joining. Yes, thank you.
Monal S: Alright guys, so we are done with today's class, and
Monal S: Rajit's asking, sir, here, input is 0 or 1. If I want input true or false.
Monal S: Rachi, as I mentioned, right, Boolean, whenever you use input, input function, it always extracts string as the input. So what? You have… you cannot directly get true and false.
Monal S: Rajesh, I'll be clear? Because it is the functionality of input itself. Input gives you true or false.
Monal S: Yes, you're welcome, guys.
Monal S: Thank you very much, guys. Thanks for joining today's session. I will see you tomorrow.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: See you guys!
Monal S: And your last answer, you were… what address?
Monal S: Repeat that sentence, or complete that sentence.
Monal S: Did I miss something?
Monal S: You were trying to answer the use of print.
Monal S: Not the use of print, but the behavior of print in notebook.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Kindly include it, please.
Monal S: It is, in the first class, when I was talking about the difference between notebook and, script, it is, you will be able to find it.
Monal S: In a very short session, okay, when I was talking about the difference between Jupyter Notebooks and .py file, I told that why we see this behavior, okay? So, it will be better for you in the short, duration that you will understand that what,
Monal S: How it differs, okay?
Monal S: Guys, I am using jellyfish. Sahul, I'm using jellyfish, okay?
Monal S: Not Cyberpunk. Cyberpunk I also use, but Jellyfish.
Monal S: Alright guys, thank you very much, we'll see you tomorrow. Bye-bye.